welcome to this wonderful Friday night
it's a bit of a slow news week bit of a
slow news day but we do have a couple
crazy stories I mean for one I don't
know if it's the lead story but Joe
Biden's finally acknowledging his it's
an illegitimate granddaughter right like
it is his granddaughter but illegitimate
I guess and then the story that I
thought was actually somewhat silly but
kind of scary because RFK JR says he was
denied Secret Service protection and uh
you know he had come out not that long
ago saying he recognizes the concern
over you know his life being taken by
intelligence agencies so I don't want to
make it seem like there is a dramatic
concern like oh no they're coming for
RFK but the fears of the possibility and
then when you hear that they're like
yeah we know you're polling at 20 for
the Democrats but uh we're not going to
protect you it's kind of like uh okay
okay I guess like they're supposed to do
this at this point I believe polling at
this level but uh I guess we'll see what
happens and then uh it has a bunch of
other stories I suppose Starbucks is a
good one they're being sued because the
woke policies that were recommended by
the Obama Administration are actually
illegal because wokeness violates the
1964 Civil Rights Act we'll talk about
that but but also we're talking a lot
about Canada
a lot of crazy stuff happening in Canada
and uh we got to pay attention to our
neighbors to the north because it's
apocalyptic before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com and
you can join the cast Brew Coffee Club
you'll get three bags of coffee every
month and you join that club and it's
fantastic the best coffee you'll ever
have it's the best coffee I've ever had
and the good news is we're able to get
back in stock the pumpkin spice and the
Stan oh I guess stand your ground is
still sold out do we not have any okay
stand your grounds I guess so we were
normally selling this is our company
please buy our coffee if you want to
support us we were selling uh light and
dark roast and a lot of people wanted
medium a medium roast and a lot of
people wanted other stuff so the pumpkin
spice went out real quick we got it back
in right away and uh but I guess our
medium roast everybody wanted it took it
all so uh you can still get our dark
roast I really do recommend Appalachian
nights the best coffee I've ever had and
uh back in stock is Mr bocus pumpkin
spice experience I recommend that as
well you get a picture of Mr Bocas on
every bag and when you buy Casper coffee
you're supporting the show because it's
our company we're sponsoring ourselves
also head over to Tim cast com become a
member by clicking join us Monday
through Thursday members only shows if
you've been a member for at least six
months you can submit questions and
actually ask our guests some questions
and also uh if you sign up the 25 per
month level we have a gatekeeping thing
to try and keep out uh nefarious actors
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Viva Fray good
evening afternoon evening it's eight
o'clock afternoon in the west coast Tim
everybody yeah well I I said before
we're talking to friends like I'll make
sure to get a dedicated bit about the
madness in Canada because I'm not sure
that enough people are sort of paying
attention to what happens North it
trickles down if it hasn't already gone
to like New York state California but
it's Madness in Canada and it's not
clear that people in the states are very
aware of it or paying the requisite
attention well there there's this woke
principle who just took his own life
because a woker person accused him of
not being woken off and thus he was
racist and so I guess the trauma of
being EXO like ostracized from the cult
must be tremendous
it's it's another terrible story there's
obviously underlying mental issues going
on with someone who responds to being
called racist or or canceled to that
degree but
um it's Madness it's it's it's the snake
eating its own tail it's uh you know the
revolution eventually devours its own
children and we're we're nearing that
point yeah well we'll uh we'll we'll
talk about all that thanks for hanging
out brother thank you Labonte of all All
That Remains how you doing I am Philip
Monte lead singer of all the remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
I think you can cross I know thank you
Phil uh good to be here good to see you
David as always if people call you Viva
Fray I'll call you David Fray probably
why it's fry height which thank you
verbatim freedom in Germany not that I
care I'm not sensitive about that what
does David mean David means um son of I
have no idea so but Freedom your last
name means freedom verbatim in German
Phi Heights fry is free and height is
the state of being so Fahrenheit is
fahren is warmth in the state of being
warmth Tennessee measure temperature
with it dude that means beloved
David means beloved Freedom how do I not
know that my first name means beloved
well let's let's go let's go from there
okay what's a nice start what's up
Kellen hey what's going on guys uh
pressing the buttons over here my name
is Kellen and you know Drake is one of
the biggest uh rappers in the world and
he's Canadian so it's uh be careful the
Hebrew name dawid which came from the
Hebrew word beloved beloved freedom I
like it wow I'll keep it I'm not
changing my name jeez
all right we got the story from the post
millennial RFK JR says Secret Service
won't provide protection as they do for
every major presidential candidate
you're literally the poster child of why
presidential candidates need protection
one Twitter user responded on Friday FK
Jr said that he had been denied Secret
Service protection a resource provided
to all major presidential candidates
since 1968 when Kennedy's father was
assassinated during his campaign after
numerous requests at the Department of
Homeland security-led panel Kennedy said
that secretary Alejandro mayorcas handed
down the official verdict telling
Kennedy that protection was not
warranted at this time I love it they
say uh Secret Service so there's context
added to his tweet on Twitter I'm sorry
on X they changed the app now like and
in the App Store it says X they say it's
afforded to Major candidates from the
period of 128 days from the general
election
typical turnaround time for pro former
protection requests from presidential
candidates is 14 days Kennedy said on
Twitter after 88 days of no response and
after several follow-ups by our campaign
the Biden Administration just denied our
request and here's where the story gets
fun
did you guys catch those numbers
oh God no no I I saw someone tweet about
that we don't have to talk about that do
we yeah I think we do because I don't
know RFK is being attacked by the left
for having the numbers 14 and the number
88 in his tweeting is stupid everything
is stupid all of the time
can I ask the stupid question 1488 now
for those who may not know that are
watching wouldn't be me I know what it
means what's the reference of 1488. it's
it's just two Nazi numbers
okay there's a good reason why I might
not know that then um what's amazing
about this it's not the way they say it
it's not warranted at this time setting
aside it's all like politically
manipulated um determinations oh well
when you reach this threshold we'll give
it to you what I find very concerning
about this is that announcing that he's
not getting it itself could be
misconstrued as something of a dog
whistle letting the entire general
public know he doesn't have Secret
Service protection and and it could just
be an error I mean they they uh the post
manual points out they all usually
provide it within 120 days I thought it
was appalling thing I guess I'm wrong
well it's a no-brainer thing is that
it's RFK whether RFK Junior whether or
not he even wants Secret Service
protection given um what has gone on in
the family history especially his father
because there is a conspiracy theorist
to who might have been the actual
shooter of his father
announcing it to the extent it's not an
outright mistake just let everybody know
he's a he's he's sitting Goose I don't
want to use a hyperbolic Expressions but
they let everybody know he'll have to
get his own security fine he might be
better off with his own Super security
but to let the entire general population
know RFK Junior we're not we're not
protecting him I was just watching a
documentary about his father Robert
Kennedy who have massive respect for and
I don't want to get any of this wrong so
I don't want to tell the story like I
know exactly but he was assassinated I
believe he gave a speech he was in a
hotel the Ambassador Hotel is that where
it was I'll get mistaken on the names as
well but going through the kitchen he
went through the kitchen where he was
directed to go in a spot where he wasn't
supposed to go you have seerhan Sirhan
who was the Man convicted of went to
jail uh just got paroled or not uh
paroled just did get parole but I think
Gavin knew some overrided the parole uh
but many believe that there was someone
who shot RFK in the back close proximity
because there was contact combustion
whatever that word is meaning proximity
of the weapon and even RFK Jr himself
does not believe Sierra and sear him
fired the shot because apparently all
bullets that came from Sirhan sirhan's
gun were accounted for and they were not
the ones that had killed RFK and he RFK
was told don't go through the kitchen is
that right his security but he didn't
listen to them and he went through the
kit or was it some other thing I think
it was the other way around where they
directed him through the kitchen where
he should not have gone as far as I know
is there a real-time fact Checker here I
mean I can pull up the and then and then
the theory is that one of the theories
is that it was actually his newly
appointed Secret Service who was behind
him from which he was shot who
purportedly through this Theory might
have been the one to pull so that's why
I brought it up is that weird
you know conspiracy theory that it may
have been his own secret service or
someone in his own whoa party that did
it or early plug if anybody really wants
to know the RFK Junior RFK JFK
conspiracy theories uh Mark Robert Eric
Hundley uh America's untold stories I
mean they go into this they know it like
like an encyclopedia and I've learned it
from them but that's my understanding
I'll read a little bit here from the
wiki uh it says Kennedy planned to walk
through the ballroom after speaking on
his way to another gathering of
supporters but reporters wanted a press
conference campaign aide Fred Dutton
decided that Kennedy would forego the
second Gathering instead go through the
hotel's kitchen and Pantry area behind
the bottom to the Press area Kennedy had
welcomed contact with the public during
the campaign and people had often tried
to touch him soon after Kennedy
concluded the speech he started to exit
through the ballroom when Barry stopped
him and said no it's been changed we're
going this way Barry and Dutton began
clearing the way from Kenny to go left
through Swinging Doors to the kitchen
Corridor but he was hemmed in by the
crowd and uh and followed maitre d Hotel
Carl U Ecker through the back exit you
acted like Kennedy to the kitchen area
holding his right wrist but frequently
releasing it as Kennedy shook hands with
people whom he encountered you Wacker
and Kennedy started down a passageway
Kennedy turned to his left and shook
hands with Juan Romero just as Sirhan
Sirhan stepped down from a low tray
stacker beside the ice machine rushed
past you Ecker and repeatedly fired an
eight-shot 22 long rifle caliber 22
caliber long rifle Iver Johnson connect
55A revolver at Point Blank Range
Kennedy fell to the floor others
including George Plimpton and Grier
tried to disarm Sirhan as he continued
firing his gun in random directions five
other people were wounded so so is the
is the theory that he did shoot but
missed the theories that he did shoot
all of his bullets were accounted for uh
because he did they held his hand as
he's firing and injuring other people
and the theory is that all of the
bullets from Sierra Han Sirhan were
accounted for which means the Mortal
shot came from somewhere else and there
was an issue if you can find it there
what is it called when the when the
muzzle is pressed up against the you
know close to the body as shoots yeah
but then there's like a combustion
discharge indicating that it was done
from you know and I forget who the
Secret Service newly appointed was he
recently died
um he said RFK had
like Point Blank residue or whatever yes
and he was the one standing behind him
so he was allegedly the only one who
could have fired the the Fatal shots
through the back and and RFK Jr has come
to this determination as well he does
not believe that Sirhan Sirhan fired the
Fatal shots there's no question that
Sierra and Sierra hadn't fired shots
yeah and all of them were accounted I
mean from a bird's eye view just
objectively the Assassin was in the
kitchen waiting for him and people right
at the last minute said hey we're gonna
change paths and move you through the
kitchen so like powder in the hell they
just happened to move them through an
area where there was assassin so what it
sounds like based off what you're saying
I I don't know this term just saying
based off what what being told it sounds
like see your hand see your hand had
accomplices high up that were to bring
RFK into this place
maybe he wasn't even the organizer
whatever but somebody wanted RFK dead
and this guy was supposed to be the guy
to do it but he failed and then someone
had to clean up finish the job now I am
not the expert on this I have only
picked the brains of the expert Barnes
uh America's untold stories that is the
theory that all of those bullets were
accounted for they were not the Fatal
ones and to make sure it happened there
was this old a new hire like a brand new
hire the individual recently died and
that's the theory so the you know
whether or not RFK Jr even wants uh I
won't say deep State the administrative
State's uh protection I mean that might
be more dangerous than not that being
said this might be one of those
situations where it's going to be damned
if you do damned if you don't because he
doesn't get that now they make the
announcement RFK Juniors left to his own
devices so you know yeah I wonder I
think it may be fair to say well
presidential candidates typically get
120 days out but don't families of
politicians who have like I wouldn't
this be a special circumstance doesn't
uh Hunter Biden obviously has C Secret
Service protection his dad's currently
the president I can understand that
but this is like a special circumstance
where I think but perhaps it's just not
procedural I well who who knows but I
not announcing that it's not there is a
an act of politics uh right and denying
it is an act of politics whether or not
they even offered he says okay I'll take
yours and I'll take my own protection as
well because you know I'm looking at
Donald Trump even if they offer some
protection I'd make sure to have my own
that I can trust as well but I think
it's important to clarify too the 120
days out thing is not particularly
relevant to the story
what everyone's saying is why would you
get protection it's not 120 days out RFK
Jr did not say I am seeking a request
for a presidential candidate under the
procedural whatever he's saying I am
asking for this in general period that's
it because of his family history because
of the threats against him because of
you know uh I should say because of his
high profile status and the medius
mirrors
he's asking for it he was denied it he
thinks he he deserves it maybe he
doesn't whatever but but I think it's a
cop-out to be alike but candidates only
get it 120 days no no RFK Jr asked for
it didn't get it and complained about it
end of story he needs it it's a
no-brainer to announce it is as much of
a dog whistle as I can imagine is a dog
whistle especially from a party that
always complains about the dog whistles
um it's it's a parent it's a parent hey
guys but we've denied him Secret Service
protection Dave Smith tweeted about the
14 and the number 88 in the Tweet
because people are like oh it's like
come on dude we went to a coffee shop
and we ordered like an iced coffee and
uh like cookies and cream gelato and it
came out to 14.88 cents oh and like oh
are they gonna go after the ice cream
shop now because it's like a secret
thing they do they used to take the
number 13 off of uh hotels no no all
buildings like uh uh yeah you don't go
to Chicago there's no 13th floor in a
lot of these buildings just explain to
me who doesn't understand this 1488 with
the reference to Hitler the 14 is the is
the 14 Words which basically is I forget
I don't remember exactly what the phrase
is it's something it's something about
like having kids I can read it off
on its nose it's just a normal yeah
H is the eighth letter of the alphabet
so eight eight you understand yeah the
eight eight I got that's like that's
like Hong Kong out of Canada apparently
yeah
I can't even believe that but it's it's
first of all by raising one oh no it's
not contractors
but it was also the clown World meme
yeah and when people would post the
videos of like the little clown Pepes
they were like Hong Kong is HH therefore
I gotta make a a correction the 14 word
slogans very racist it's not a normal
thing
why the
the irony is by raising these idiotic
issues they just make them more
prevalent oh there's gonna be a lot of
people who never even understood this
that are not going to say good I'll
appropriate that and now I'm going to
use 1488 when I want to make a point I
mean to that to your point that's the
the argument or one of the best
arguments against using Marxist racial
theory in schools because you make
racists if you've got like you don't
want to have an awakened critical
conscious critical racial Consciousness
if you're trying to not look at people
based on their race and if you awaken a
critical Consciousness you and you you
by definition make people see race first
it's illiberal that that was the biggest
argument again I want to go back to the
RFK thing because I want to read this in
a 2018 interview with the Washington
Post RFK Jr said he traveled to
California to meet with Sirhan in prison
and that after a relatively long
conversation details of which he would
not disclose he believed siren did not
kill his father and then second gunman
was involved let's let's let's drive the
conspiracy theory even deeper what if
Sirhan a fan of RFK was in the kitchen
and he saw whoever was setting up stop
him can you uh just Google very briefly
I think there is Sirhan Sirhan MK Ultra
type brainwashing that's alleged to have
occurred with Sirhan Sirhan
um which would explain why
uh when he was when he was going for
parole and the most recent time he got
it he was told do not invoke the
defenses that you've been using
previously which was blackout drunk I
think like I was blackout drunk and when
shooting there's a a very serious okay
good but very serious uh theory that
Sirhan Sirhan was a victim subject of MK
Ultra type brainwashing ABC News
assassin's lawyer says Sirhan Sirhan was
brainwashed a lawyer for siren siron the
confessed Assassin of RFK plans to
present new evidence at a parole board
hearing suggesting that he did not act
alone was potentially brainwashed and
cannot remember anything about the 43
year old shooting
yep and and granted parole and Gavin
Newsom overrides what is it uh the
lawyer's tale has all the makings of a
great conspiracy theory if not a science
fiction Thriller akin to The Manchurian
Candidate can you understand that that
mainstream media says this this article
is what now this is uh 12 uh 12 years
old can you imagine they say it's
conspiracy theory Manchurian Candidate
as though operation MK Ultra did not
exist and did not do the things
operation Northwoods was a thing and JFK
was like nah yeah NYX is it Department
of Defense says MK Ultra it was like I
believe now explain if you know more but
it was like a mind control program where
they put people in psychedelics and then
tell them voluntary voluntary
psychedelics and involuntary and it
actually has a connection to Montreal
there was the Allen Memorial which is
the mental institution in Montreal where
they would test on mentally ill people
homeless people and the idea was this is
coming out of the Cold War as far as I
understand and I'm I'm free to make
mistakes on this but I'm pretty sure I
got it uh they were testing basically to
see if they could
um administer drugs to get people to
tell the truth or effectively just to
mess with their brains and and get them
to do crazy things or for or you know
disclose secrets and so it involved
involuntary intoxication like like dope
dosing up people with LSD without
telling them uh it involved
experimenting on homeless people
mentally ill people and institutions and
it's what it was this is what they were
trying to do it went on for for decades
it's I mean it was institutionalized
illegal so I pulled it up it was uh
Wikipedia says it was an illegal human
experimentation program designed and
undertaken by the US CIA intended to
develop procedures and identify drugs
that could be used during interrogations
to weaken people and force confessions
through brainwashing and psychological
torture
the people
people out there who don't know this and
then read that bullcrap article from ABC
where they call it a conspiracy theory
it was implemented I won't say policy
programs by the government and but for
the fact that it's been disclosed or I
don't know how it was revealed um you
know and people still think it's
conspiracy theory yeah mind control it's
it's it's a conspiracy theory no you
know they were trying to do it
conspiracy theorists have a pretty good
track record at this point Unfortunately
they are more accurate than CNC
unfortunately for the U.S uh government
and for our sense of reality it's a good
thing that people are exposing nonsense
you know operation northwards for those
who don't know I mean everybody should
know this that was the plan to basically
stage domestic terrorist attacks blame
it on the Cuban government so they could
justify public sentiment of a war
against Cuba and it would involve uh
domestic terrorism I think it involves
shooting plane blowing up planes uh and
it involves it fabricating or or you
know falsifying terrorist attacks but
also carrying them out on uh U.S oil to
create public sentiment for a war that
they wanted to fight it sounds very
similar to I don't know something that
happened in 2001. they wanted to have
like people wearing Americans wearing
Cuban outfits like planes flying Cuban
flight flying into buildings I think
there were some they wanted mass
shootings it was they wanted to have
people run on the beaches and look like
an invading force and Kennedy said look
look John Kennedy said no and a year and
a half later they yeah later he passed
on what was that let's get the
microphone there a year and a half later
what what happened happened and and but
for JFK vetoing this this made it all
the way up it's not it's not like oh
some crackpot down on the lower chain
this was like right up there JFK said no
Shane where's Shane at Shane Cashman
yeah he knows oh yeah he's the authority
he was he wrote this he was writing a
story about the Long Island killer
serial killer so like he know this is
his wheelhouse he knows all this stuff
reality is Stranger Than Fiction and yet
you still have mainstream media that's
calling this conspiracy theory it's
reality conspiracy I'll tell you this if
there is anything
on this planet that makes me consider
quitting this job more than anything it
is the knowledge the fact-based
knowledge I have that everything we talk
about when it comes to news is wrong
what I mean is when a news report comes
out and says like Joe Biden did thing
like it's not true his PR people are
lying spokesperson is lying the
journalists are lying and then when it
comes to war and conflict in Ukraine the
intelligence agencies are lying and so
I'm like I know right now there's two
dudes in the CIA and they're like
hanging out in a break room Tim cast IRL
is live they're sipping their coffee and
they're laughing being like
his morons don't know what they're
talking about
you can do you can basically take the
mainstream media headline of the day and
assume that it is 100 inverted Incorrect
and it's not conspiracy theory is the
way of writing off people I think
they've recently oh sorry no the most
recent conspiracy theory was over
counting covert deaths um now confirmed
but it's just like they they call it
conspiracy theory until they can't deny
it who was it that said it's not a
question of controlling what they know
it's a question of controlling when they
know it and so it's it's a beautiful
expression I've mangled it but the idea
being eventually the truth will come out
it's not a question of denying people uh
the truth because you can't keep the
truth hidden forever it's just a
question of making sure it comes out you
know later on when they're all fatigued
and they no longer care about the fact
that they overestimated kova deaths
apparently by x amount and that was are
you referencing because they were
counting people that died with covid
that maybe got into a motorcycle
accident as like a CO that covid had
killed them what are the rules of the
discussion here and what capacity oh
okay we're like there's no regarding
like uh miscalculating kova deaths if
someone had it but then they like got
into a motorcycle accident they'd say
that was a coveted death so
there was a metric of died with covid
and I I think you understand that it
means quite literally what that what it
says
the rules in terms of not getting in
trouble I don't know to discuss it the
cover stuff's pretty cooled down now but
I just don't make claims that I don't
have evidence for it but but the whole
medical stuff is what they're actually
going after people okay well
whatever I'll just report what they
announced in Canadian news and the
doctor said you know we are we were not
distinguishing died with versus died
from covet and now the New York Times
came with an article basically
confirming as much saying we've
attributed x amount of deaths to died
with but first of all you can never have
a number when they were not
distinguishing between hospitalized with
versus hospitalized uh there was I think
the chief medical officer of Illinois
came out and said this like understand
we're saying with not from like they
were very clear about it
right right Coco came out and said it
and then you got um look this is the
important distinction
the media lies often time I think this
is what Alex Jones said they will tell
you there's a bear trap and if you're
too stupid and you walk into it it's
your own fault the the you had Illinois
you had hokel you had you had
politicians telling you outright
explicitly they weren't lying they were
saying died with not from but the media
would then insinuate or write things to
make it sound a certain way yeah they
were I think they were indicating it on
on the death certificates in a way that
would allow for this confusion you
reminded me of one where when the media
one last thing go for it always go and
talk to your doctor about what's right
for you no take medical advice from
podcaster that's if you trust your
doctor now if you come to like the black
pill Viva who do you trust anymore you
have to know a doctor to be able to
trust what they're telling you
absolutely and set a conversation
I look if I always say this like if you
if you've got a plumber and you don't
trust them you should not have that
plumber if you've got a doctor don't
trust them find one you do trust and
everybody says to me like oh all the
doctors are bad I'm like clearly not all
doctors are bad right like Trump has
doctors of course he's getting good
treatment there's celebrities and stuff
people say yeah it's expensive trust me
man maybe he's got to call West Virginia
because Maga country's got Maga doctors
and if you if if you're concerned about
certain ideas trust me the Maga doctors
know what you're talking about just find
a doctor who can answer your questions
there you go well especially once you've
lost faith because the doctor may have
said one thing which is a litmus test in
terms of reliability but I I just
remember the headline to say when the
media says something if you bet against
the media headline you'll probably write
more often than not I don't know if you
heard about this out of Canada when
there was allegedly a protester calling
Justin Trudeau a pathetic Jew I don't
know if you heard about this no no so it
was the friends of the Simon wiesenthal
Center who put out a tweet saying
anti-Semitism is out of control we can't
tolerate this hate a protester calling
Justin Trudeau a pathetic Jew is Justin
Trudeau Jewish no we'll get there it's
even worse and then another member of
liberal government uh Garretts and Mark
Erickson puts out a tweet and says oh we
stand against anti-semitism together and
I just said not knowing anything I said
look the chances that this person was
calling Justin Trudeau a Roman Catholic
as far as I know and a subservient
political horror to Klaus Schwab also
not a Jew the chances of that they're
calling him a pathetic Jew doesn't make
any sense I'm just going to venture that
right now turns out aggregate knowledge
of the interwebs gets out there tweaks
the audio of the recording it's either
pathetic puke or pathetic Juke because
it's clearly a uke and so the story
Falls you know Falls by the wayside but
only after you know anti-Semitism On The
Rise makes headlines on the twitterverse
of Canadian liberal let's let's jump to
a different story here um I got some
apocalyptic news for you guys let's go
the post ammonia reports largest U.S
power grid faces level one emergency as
Biden's decarbonization policies take
effect record-breaking temperatures are
hitting all the big cities not to
mention these Canadians are trying to
choke us out you know we got our power
grid our power went out uh uh at our new
facility the power now it was a storm
though they say on Thursday though
largest U.S power grid operator pjm
interconnection LLC issued with level
one emergency over concerns they would
not be able to maintain adequate power
reserves as customers deal with
scorching temperatures according to
Bloomberg pjm issued a call for all
power plants to operate full capacity to
deal with the increased use of air
conditioners as much of the country went
under a heat advisory
so this is not so much about Biden's
policies it's more so that uh I guess
it's a hot summer it's bloody hot well
what are they saying it's like the
hottest hottest month on record or
something or the hottest day it's
because we didn't pay enough in carbon
taxes last year and therefore you
haven't seen the immediate uh payoff of
increased carbon tax you know what I
love though I love the meme where it's
like the climate change policy
politicians are proof the government can
control the weather
that's funny right
it's it's first of all we can all agree
on the RFK Junior principle pollution is
bad we want to enact policies that
doesn't result in more pollution the
idea that we're going to control carbon
emissions and that's going to have an
immediate effect on the environment okay
if you believe that uh and I'll talk to
Trudeau again if you believe that
crippling the Canadian economy which
represents 1.5 percent of global
emissions is not what you want what you
want to someone who's going to be harder
on China which would have ironically
been not the person that you have in the
white house now in the states so it's
it's it's it's asked backwards from
beginning to end even if you believe the
premises of the uh the climate I mean
look but I don't I think that trying to
stop people from producing waste is a
misguided effort they're gonna poop
they're gonna burn stuff to stay warm
and to stay cool you need to reuse the
waste it is we need a global effort to
reuse the carbon dioxide and methane
coming out of those machines true but I
I don't think when people are talking
about that type of reducing waste I'm
curious to know like you know in Canada
by the way now you can't get plastic
straws so it's all this this at all at
all can't get plastic Cutlery so you're
getting I don't know what it's made out
of I don't know what the environmental
footprint it's it's it might be like
cornmeal stuff straws or paper straws
are actually paper so you go get a
Starbucks coffee you better drink it
fast because your straw is not going to
last that should be the new logo hold on
what if we replace straws with cookies
you ever had those cookie straws no I
mean this sounds delicious yeah what
they do is they line it's a cookie and
the inside is lined with chocolate so
when you're drinking it doesn't dissolve
the and then you eat the straw after
that I think you're gonna get diabetes
and all sorts of other issues ah come on
just a cookie what's giving you diabetes
is the is the cookie crumble mocha frap
with two pumps of vanilla and caramel
and caramel on top you know if you just
did a regular cold brew with a cookie
straw you're good but you know maybe
yeah but the thing that I I do wonder I
don't know what the carbon footprint or
the emission footprint is even of the
Corn compressed meal Cutlery or the
paper straws the dye that goes into that
like I don't know what the cost benefit
has been done to determine that this is
better for the environment than that
other than a simple plastic bad this is
paper therefore it's good if you don't
know how the process you know what goes
into that in the first place it could be
even worse like electric cars it could
be even worse than I think we should ban
air conditioners
just outright today yes right now and uh
based I you know what I'm thinking I'm
thinking we want to crank the heat up on
the people who uh don't work who are
entitled who are demanding so my
attitude is like let me tell you if
tomorrow you know aliens came down and
just went like and press the button and
all air conditioners disappeared
I would I would be okay now in all
seriousness a lot of elderly people and
people who are at risk yeah we don't
really want that my point is we have
such luxury and the pollution all the
stuff we're talking about it's typically
not the people listening to this show
it's typically not the people in rooms
like this we're when you come out into
the country what do you what do I see
solar panels generators chickens septic
systems the people who live outside of
cities are living substantially more
sustainable lives than people in the
cities the people in the cities are
overwhelmingly Democrat voting for
policies why it's obvious they want
things and they want to make sure that
everyone has to cut back so they can
maintain their standard of living it
scales up the ultra wealthy why are so
you know we talk about them buying
property on beachfronts and flying in
private jets they say everyone's got to
cut back everyone's got to cut back
because of global warming what they're
really saying is if you don't cut back I
don't get to fly on my jet you all
better cut back so I can keep flying on
my private jet yep because I'm important
my time is important I'm needed oh
because it feels good gotta spread the
word you gotta you gotta go City to City
complaining about uh carbon emissions we
love air conditioning that's my point
and there are people in these cities who
have everything handed them fresh
running water clean running water
Refrigeration air conditioning and they
complain they deserve more and I'm not
saying people don't deserve to live
better lives I'm just saying like at a
certain point you got a big city it is
polluting like crazy it is concentrating
human waste and not just in the
biological but in the in the in the
consumers Pharmaceuticals
Pharmaceuticals Plastics people out in
the middle nowhere are not large
contributors to a lot of this look we
have our own eggs people who live out in
the country they're more likely to have
backyard chickens they don't go and buy
plastic cartons of eggs they are less
likely to contribute to the problem but
in these cities they're voting for
policies to force the people who are
doing things right to live crappier
standards so they can maintain their
their awful standards well I don't get I
think that the mentality is okay they
want to shut down some power I don't
know what Biden's plan is right now
that's threatening to uh annihilate our
electrical grid but it's like
okay too much too much air conditioning
uh but it requires the pollution to get
the air conditioning so we need to make
these people suffer by turning off their
air conditioning
and I'm not getting this out properly no
this is what I think the Biden mentality
is is like we need less oil burning so
we need these people to take they're
going to have to suffer they're not
going to get their air conditioning
because the only way for them to get air
conditioning is to create pollution and
the pollution is too dangerous so he's
going to make people use electricity I
don't understand I got solutions for
everybody you know we can build
structures that remain cool that while I
was going to say you're talking in the
big city environment you are talking
about more pavement more heat in and of
itself out and Out in the Country it's
green grass it's still hot but like you
say Tim I mean I noticed a lot of open
windows and clothes drying outside
instead of in dry cleaning in drying
machines whatever they're called I mean
if if we fundamentally changed the way
we build homes and we built down set of
us they'd be they'd be cooler uh so we
have Geo at our studio we have
geothermal heating and cooling
underground tends to be around 50 some
odd degrees so when it's cold outside
you you concentrate heat from
underground and start bringing that in
granted there's a little bit more to it
but uh for our air conditioning it's
ridiculously low energy relative to
compression because all we are doing is
pulling heat from from the room and then
running it underground to dissipate it
where it's cold so it's a lot easier and
cheaper to cool
you could build downward structures and
not need heavy air conditioning in fact
back in the day how would they keep food
cold to preserve it they put in the
basement now it's like it's the craziest
thing that we've abandoned all of that
basic Pantry stuff because we just have
refrigerators
it's like well we should do both I mean
we shouldn't get rid of good traditional
practices which save energy and prolong
life just because it got easier but this
is the reality of it in France people
can't ride horses anymore because we
have cars and we say nobody needs to
learn how to ride a horse anymore well
there's a funny it was a funny meme
about cargo ships using kites to
preserve energy and they're literally
doing this kites are very different from
sales but it's a similar principle uh
sales can you can actually sale I'm not
a sailing expert many of you listening
probably know but I know that you can go
like 45 degrees at the wind and then Tic
Tac left and right to sail you know
forward when the wind is blowing at you
that's how you move in that direction
kites more so is what I was told by a
sailing guy they launch when they're
when they have the win at their backs
why did we ever stop using that simply
because we invented the combustion
engine or the steam engine right we
should absolutely utilize these things
but you know what if uh
my recommendation to people is to learn
where in your life you can do these
things so it cuts your costs like having
your own chickens growing your own food
first of all chickens are great your
chickens put out I was talking to
someone earlier like 10 to 12 eggs a day
no it's like 30. that's yeah we have
many chickens I think when it's hotter
they make more yeah that's amazing you
have an animal that craps out food that
you can eat for breakfast and if you eat
it and then you crap it up it's like
they eat the bugs and give us eggs the
eggs and they make more like unless
you're eating eggs every day you're
gonna fall behind oh we can't keep up
dude we have 30 employees but it's not
like everyone's gonna eat an egg every
day so we made deviled eggs the other
day we had a bunch those are good by the
way yeah very delicious in France they
did a Green it's like a green roof
policy in 2015 of March and it says that
all new commercial buildings need to
either have uh plants on the roof
partially covering the roofs or solar
panels we have places like that in U.S
cities the problem is like Tim was
saying they have large pollution centers
these major cities and each 10 15 story
buildings All Glass and air conditioning
is one of the worst greenhouse gas
contributors so if you do want to do
something stop building All Glass
structures and then trying to cool them
in Miami no it makes no sense I have a
theory
I think that a lot of what's going on is
nothing to do with climate change and it
had nothing to do with covet has
everything to do with war
we talked about this during the covet
lockdowns one of the one of the biggest
things that changed was working from
home
you have a company in New York
major economic hub
a company uh based out of there has a
thousand employees they all work in the
same building one nuclear strike on New
York and that company ceases to exist
massive economic downturn for the for
the United States
they even had that New York PSA about
what to do in the event of a nuclear
strike take a shower wash your clothes
covet happens people spread out leave
cities many wealthier people leave
cities decentralized making it harder to
destroy these companies and begin
working remotely creating a
decentralized network of the US economy
all at the same time we're concerned
about war with China
I've been thinking about this with solar
panels there is one tremendous benefit
to having solar panels we have solar
panels at our new studio that we're
building and we have uh backup batteries
I do not have them because I'm like I'm
helping the environment I know that it
actually takes more energy to produce
these things than you'll get out with
unless you wait like 30 years I have it
so that I can have power when the power
goes out and the show can go on it's a
backup for the show we have backup
batteries all over the place here
because if it rains the show will not
shut down granted we you know you got to
back up some on backups at the new
facility we have a ridiculous solar
system and a ridiculous backup battery
system so the whole whole building can
be powered for like three days in the
event of a major power outage
the real benefit to solar power is if
there is a strike on on the US or an
attack on the grid
decentralized power generation through
solar or otherwise means we will not be
shut down completely and so I think a
large component of why they're pushing
the stuff is because they don't want to
come out and say we genuinely fear with
the fall of the Petro dollar and the
China and China's potential incursion in
Taiwan and Russia into Ukraine world war
three is on the horizon so y'all better
start prepping for it they don't want
Panic they want economic upturn and they
want policies that will move people into
a direction that will protect us in the
event of a major war I'm not saying
that's the only component I'm saying
it's a large component yeah or natural
disaster something could knock out the
electric or the electric Grid's super
super vulnerable those power lines are
above ground just sitting there out in
the open all those power lines there I
mean there's Target vulnerable targets
so I see what you're saying in uh World
War II I think it was World War II well
I'll put it this way at a Grand Central
Station there was like a main Central
controller for the railroad track or
something like that for switching the
lines like the and it was you had to go
through a secret message to find it
because they were concerned that German
saboteurs would go in and shut down
Grand Central Station which would
massively disrupt U.S economic
operations which is a key strategy in
winning a war I I learned that story and
I see what's going on and I'm like man
if a new kid's New York this economy is
like like 20 30 off you know oh it's not
it's not a not a crazy idea
um but I think if a new kids New York
um the solar panels are for individual
existence I don't think we're worrying
about an economy anymore we're worrying
about you know individual existence but
that's it's look that's an I don't know
an interesting theory is to not be
dependent on the grid honestly but but a
nuke I use that as like a more of a
device not a literal obviously something
catastrophic that hits if it's a another
911 nuclear power plant gets sabotaged
and the grid goes down or you know real
quick meteor strike EMP solar flares but
I don't I do think
a consideration is Right natural
disasters can we as an economy survive
in these circumstances and I do think a
component is are we weak because we've
centralized too much of our economy and
our grid not weak vulnerable vulnerable
right that's what I mean week two a
particular attack vulnerable is a better
word crazy thing is it's the whole
planet I mean maybe not the whole planet
they're probably places in fact I think
in Africa they leapfrogged basically
20th century power sources and then they
just went straight from like having no
electricity to having solar panels on
their roofs so someone super chatted
saying in Massachusetts your solar needs
to be connected the grid if the grid
goes down your power goes down not true
I mean I don't know about Massachusetts
they have this special policy but uh
your electric always has to be on the
grid because your solar does unless you
literally remove yourself from the grid
if you're on the grid it's a it's a
circuit so you have to get permission to
connect your solar to the grid
if you just want a closed solar system
you don't have to be on the grid I have
one we have the van we have a van and
it's got solar power and batteries and
it can it can run for it can run a
computer for like three days straight
with no like as of right now if the
solar was gone the sun just disappeared
computer would run for three days but
with solar it runs indefinitely because
it absorbs more energy it generates more
energy than it than it dissipates than
it uses it's got an air conditioner in
there that'll suck up all the juice in a
matter of like eight to ten hours or
whatever but the point is what you're
referring to is that because everyone's
home is already on the grid connecting
solar means connecting solar to the
Circuit you need to you need permission
for that I'm pretty sure you can create
your own solar or just have a backup a
backup battery it wouldn't make sense it
wouldn't make sense if the solar would
go out if the if the grid shuts down
because it derives its energy from
elsewhere other than that's the point
grid I was I was actually just talking
to two people I met up at the Harpers
Ferry who were hiking the Appalachian
Trail they had done a thousand miles and
they're going all the way up to Maine
yeah it's totally cool they they have
their totally independent autonomous
until they get to town they butt their
posers because if they actually want to
do the Appalachian Trail they got to go
to I think Scotland well okay I don't
they're not poses they they left in
March and they've done like a thousand
one hundred miles and had like solar
panels to charge because they had the
phone I was asking how you how you
connect whatsoever do you charge up when
you get to town but uh no it's totally
cool but yeah the Appalachian trails it
goes through Scotland so if you really
want to do it goes through Scotland how
do you how do you cross the Atlantic uh
I'm I'm half kidding I'm just pointing
out that oh you mean it goes underwater
the the range goes all the way towards
Scotland you know yeah the southern end
of the international Appalachian Trail
so that would mean technically the
Appalachian Trail mountain range itself
goes underwater across the Atlantic and
then it does submerged the ridge it goes
straight across because it used to be
like back way back when when the I don't
know stormed it would they were
connected yeah but I'm just being silly
so continue no no
it was it was very cool they were they
were basically off the grid for months
but they had their solar panel things to
charge their phones and whatever and
remain mildly connected it's because the
Earth is expanding that's why uh the
solar that's why the appalachian's over
there the things are moving there's this
expanding Earth theory you guys ever see
that no it's wicked awesome dude every
solar body the sun's expanding so this
theory is that as the Earth twists open
it used to just be all rock
gravitational expansion or heat
expansion or mass expansion it's
probably being pulled open
probably yeah I mean because you know
that's got a vacuum I don't know
I don't believe scientists consider this
to be true I don't know I'm not going to
study the stuff but uh I mean
theoretically with entropy and
radioactive decay it makes sense that
Earth would expand as
Things Fall Apart there there's
conflicting forces right there's the
heat expansion from the core then if
it's if it stops heating then it would
contract versus I would imagine some
sort of centripetal expansion if it
spins faster I think that's what's
happening yeah I mean it could be a
combination of a bunch of things but as
it twists open it rips apart it's C at
the seams which you see these deep
trenches and the oceans where it's
ripping open hydrogen shooting out
mixing with the oxygen in the atmosphere
to create all this water I think that's
where the water on Earth came from let's
let's Okay
I remember having read that 50 of the
Earth's water came from comets which
would be one of the stronger Arguments
for extraterrestrial life but that's
where I learned it but it I that's a lot
of comments speaking of hellish
Landscapes and nightmarish places on
Earth let's talk about Canada
this is going to be a long bit okay this
is one story that's but this goes into a
lot viva's getting ready Toronto
principal who was mobbed after false
accusation of racism takes his own life
yo sad story man I wish this guy didn't
do it I wish his family well I'll give
you the quick version of it there was an
anti-anti-racist uh individual who
claimed that in some School curriculum
curriculum that the U.S was Canada was
more racist than the U.S the principal
said well I agree Canada is racist I
certainly don't think we're more racist
than the U.S so they attacked him
started emailing complaining they wanted
him fired they called him a racist
Canada is more racist and you know what
I gotta say that woman was correct
Canada is more racist than the US
America's the best we're just perfect at
everything and you guys are awful can
you believe this level of
self-flagellation like look who look who
thinks he's nothing is the is the old
joke
um first of all it's it's terrible
there's obviously anybody who's gonna
take their own life because of
circumstances like this there's I would
suspect more deeper underlying
psychological issues
um and when it comes to this type of
thing I you know in the practice of my
legal career I came across two incidents
where traumatizing uh suicide uh you
know things that occurred in the context
of my practice might always say like you
know whatever you're feeling if that's
you're thinking just wait another day
and talk to someone you can do it
tomorrow and then you know keep doing
that over and over again something
deeper was obviously going on with this
individual but the the idea that they're
sitting there trying to argue that
Canada is more racist in the states no
the states is more racist in Canada as
far as the world goes whatever whatever
imperfections of both America and Canada
exist I would still say they're two of
the greatest Nations uh on Earth where
it's you know the best to be anybody by
no means perfect Canada a little less so
but uh tell us about your your country
good sir as to how it is that this guy
who is woke himself he was he was he was
not he's not a Maga Republican this guy
was as far as I understand was a very
Lefty individual himself and this is
what happens the mob turns on itself the
the revolution devours its own children
and nobody is woke enough nobody is
nobody hates themselves enough and then
you you a mob lands on this individual
and some people are not prepared to deal
with that type of barrage of hatred uh
you know not death threats but like go
kill yourself type comments and some
people are are succumb to the the these
terrible ideas that you know this is the
solution this is the permanent solution
to a temporary problem there's another
story that I'm not going to get into the
specific details of because it's a big
graphic but there's an individual who
underwent uh affirmation surgery which
was botched and thus because of the pain
they requested the Canadian government
terminate oh God that is the worst will
can we can we embark on the segment of
Canadian Madness right now you got you
got this story which is not a tip of the
iceberg it's a symptom of the people
you're a refugee I'm a uh I'm literally
right now driving from Montreal back to
the free state of Florida politically
glad you made it through safe sir
political Sanctuary the um you got Maids
medical assistance in dying as a program
in Canada 2016. Supreme Court says it's
unconstitutional to deny medical
assistance in dying to the terminally
ill liberal government comes in and says
okay well we're going to enact
legislation that we're going to amend
the criminal code we're going to allow
for it and at the time I think it was on
basically unsolicited it was a liberal
Member of Parliament said well we don't
want to discriminate against the
mentally ill we want to allow the
mentally ill people who are men who are
by legal definition incapable of consent
when it comes to certain judicial acts
this is physically painful
it's going to get worse we don't want to
let we don't want to deny them the
constitutional right to end their own
lives so we're going to allow mentally
ill people to commit suicide sorry to
medical assistance in time euthanasia or
as it was once called a project action I
think
um they said okay we're gonna Grant
we're going to Sunset that class we're
going to in we're going to include the
exclusion for now but that exclusion is
going to fade into the sunset in I think
it's March 2024.
within five years like medical
assistance in dying went from the
hundreds to over 10 000 in 2021 the
number people are you know guessing what
it's going to be in 2022 is it's
expected to be about 17 000. 10 064
Canadians were put to death through this
medical assistance and dying law in 2021
that represents three percent of all
death in Canada is is government induced
medical assistance well but
I mean three percent of all death in
Canada coming from the government this
is
government authorization just because
this is like a country that is trying to
come off as Progressive and woke
literally enacting the most psychotic
eugenics
that you can imagine they're literally
the most atrocious Behavior since like
it's probably since the the Progressive
Era like when they were doing lobotomies
and and and the kinds of eugenics there
was that woman who was in the commercial
saying that she was happy that she'd be
she would finally Simons it was a
Simon's clothing did this tribute to the
woman who ended her own life wait
Simon's clothing yes Simon's clothing
and it wasn't it wasn't her video that
they sponsored they produced the video
right and so listen this woman wanted
medical treatment the Canadian
government said no and she said that if
I don't get this then I don't want to
live and they said you got it there
might be two different stories there the
one from the Simon store uh the the the
the kicker to that story was not that it
wasn't that situation where someone
needed a housing and the government said
no and that she ended up getting medical
treatment with her case in the Simon's
situation I think she wanted it I don't
think it was about being denied
treatment the kicker there was that she
didn't have a terminal illness she had
um it's hardening on the arteries right
and I'm pretty sure she had sought
treatment a couple years ago and the
Canadian government said we will not
provide this treatment for you and then
she responded
okay well I'm in pain then and I don't
want to live and they were like you got
it I'm not aware of that it would not
surprise me if that were when I heard
about that story and it was Simon's the
clothing store doing this video it's
called Beauty in everything or
everything is beauty uh and I thought
the the kick in the groin kicking the
teeth kicker of that story was that she
wasn't terminally ill it was a condition
which caused pain which reduced life
expectancy but was not a terminal
illness and just did anybody watching
who's saying Viva is a heartless bastard
um having lived through uh close family
members who who died of cancer my
father-in-law I can understand it and I
actually do support the idea of ending
someone's suffering and misery when
there's no no no no Prospect of she
wanted to live women featured employee
finisher wanted to live National Post
December I feel like I'm falling through
the cracks so if I'm not able to access
health care am I then able to access
death care she said in a CTV interview
on she wanted to live and because you
Canadians have Nazi health Care Systems
I'm being somewhat hyperbolic Mercy
killings it's called Mercy
Mercy killings because you're in Canada
so like everyone in Canada should get
immersed first of all it's like I use
Lily tomlin's expression in my Twitter
header no matter how cynical you are
it's hard to keep up I I feel like I'm
as black pill as I was gonna get and I
was not familiar with this aspect of the
story yeah I was I thought the aspect
that I knew is that she was internally
ill that was shocking enough it was a
chronic pain thing it's it's and now by
the way they want to extend it to minors
they want to extend it to minors without
the consent or the minor if the minor
can't consent what it's oh and it's not
like don't worry it's it's not gonna
increase health care costs it might
actually save Healthcare that's why I
feel like there's a motivation like is
there like some billionaire out there
who's just sitting in his chair being
like I hate Canada yeah I really I do I
don't want to say it's like an all-claus
Schwab type thing but Canada is a if
there were a country in which to test
these types of theories to see will
people do it Canada would be the country
to do it polite subservient uh deferring
to Authority you try to do something
like that in the states depending on the
state it won't get very far but that's
that's
the madness in Canada you got your Maids
we'll see what the 2022 numbers are uh
if if I can three percent of all three
three points to zero three percent ten
thousand sixty four the number is only
going to be more in 2022 and by a lot is
that what what's the so well the largest
cause that's probably like like heart
defect or like heart disease or
something I would imagine I thought it
was dementia for a little while but um
it seems that very recently deaths of
unknown causes at least in Alberta
overtook dementia as as the leading I
want to hear more about the madness but
first I feel like this is like a
response to maybe not directly to covid
but like in America we've got a lot of
homelessness now a lot of people going
on the street so that's like if you've
if you're from despair there was there
was a poll apparently a poll in Canada
Tim you can find this one it said I
think it was like a third of all
Canadians supported medical assistants
and dying for homelessness there was a
woman she had there was a woman who had
multiple chemical sensitivity allergies
severe allergies couldn't find proper
housing applied for medical assistance
and dying got it and then and then you
know when they when a vet calls up uh
for for PTSD services and they
unsolicited mention have you thought
about killing yourself what this is a
true story what is the the motivation
for the state to say no we do not
approve your request for medical Aid and
dying there's no the only incentive is
to approve it and it requires two
professionals to agree to it yeah then I
I mean I I it's and all of the incentive
the the financial incentive from the
state is that it saves money because
they're not going to be getting Health
Services for so so the rest of their
life let me we'll try and do some math
real quick there you said it was three
percent three percent ten thousand
deaths was three percent of the annual
deaths you got to go reverse from there
to get the total number of deaths what
is three percent of one hundred thousand
three thousand three thousand very I
just Google searched uh who dot int top
10 causes of death in Canada and uh
I think this is Canada
maybe it's not uh I pulled up a couple
of them but because they break down
death by all these very specific things
it's not necessarily fair to say that
made is the leading cause of death
because there's a bunch of different
ailments that are leading people to want
to end their lives but if you were to
just say
outside of any diagnosis the government
taking someone's life is the cause of
death I believe it would be the number
one cause of it wouldn't be the number
one but it would be I mean it would be
top five it wouldn't be number one
because
look three percent of the aggregate
deaths I'd have to look I'd have to
refresh my memory on that but it
wouldn't be number one because number
one were things like cancer heart
disease and to clarify the government's
not having their lives it's authorizing
them their own the government is
authorized medical professionals to
authorize and administer and by the way
you want to get one next level uh down
into this conspiracy theory Rabbit Hole
of of of
insanity Nova Scotia New Brunswick
recently enacted uh they called it the
Allen Law in Nova Scotia or New
Brunswick I forget which one presumed
consent for tissue harvesting
presumed consent so they're going to
change the law to be that you have to
opt out of organ doning organ donation
tissue donation and you're presumed to
have opted in unless you opt out every
citizen every every there's some
criteria as to how long you've had to
live in The Province but it's the trend
now presumption of organ donation tissue
donation and by the way you don't even
have to be dead for it to happen yet you
can have a medical profession I forget
what they're called not the corner but
basically someone's determined you're
close enough to dying uh so therefore
you're presumed to have don't uh you
know surrendered your tissue you were
right the stats I was looking at wasn't
wasn't uh uh wasn't conveying the
numbers in a way that was easily
translatable so that was wrong uh cancer
is number one this is interesting Canada
cancer is higher than heart disease in
the U.S heart disease is higher uh covet
as number three accidents
cerebrovascular diseases chronic lower
respiratory diseases than diabetes so it
would be the seventh leading cause of
death however the way they probably
classified is
I don't know exactly if here's what I
imagined they would do if you have
cancer and then you ask the government
to take your life they'll say it was a
cancer death is that 2021 I think that
David was saying was from 2021 yeah 2021
were the numbers so there is also some
theorizing that the the numbers for
medical assistants and dying are
actually underreported uh that's
something that you will only find out in
due time the information will come out
they're just going to control the weight
I got to know a little bit more about
the madness but first how black pilled
are you on a percentage the struggle is
not to give up the struggle is just to
remain cheery and remain good-natured as
I've always been I mean I will it's just
the struggle is to remain optimistic and
uh not happy but cheery I guess and to
not become cynical jaded and angry
fulfilled because I think happiness and
fulfillment are two different things
well that's I mean I'm feeling
definitely fulfilled in terms of the Ika
guy that I found in life now uh but it's
difficult not to get cynical to the
point of saying holy crap I I don't
really want to go into the mountains and
just live alone but uh nor do I want to
lose faith in humanity but I
just you know buy a studio in the West
Virginia mountains and you know hire
some people Tim you've certainly I I
kind of say yeah I can get used to this
although I've kind of built my own my
own refugees my house you know we've uh
one room studio and we live with our
family and a good Community do you have
chicken I do not have chickens we can't
have chickens I looked into it it's
crazy it's terrible but Florida yeah
well before it depends on it's got like
you have an HOA or something
yeah dude I said I wouldn't do an HOA
but whatever it happened but uh just Ian
just to get to the madness let's we have
our own January 6th type Madness so very
few people I think in America have ever
heard of the Coots for these are four
individuals who have been detained since
the trucker protest these four
individuals were basically the
accusations against them served as the
basis for invoking the emergencies act
under Justin Trudeau because the
accusations were this peaceful protest
in Ottawa there was equal protests out
in a place called Coots Alberta and
these four individuals allegedly
according to the charges conspired to
commit murder against an RCMP officer
it's a Royal Canadian mountain police
these guys are are neo-nazis these guys
are three of the four have outright
clean records They had jobs they had
families one of the four from what I
understand had a record from juvenile uh
but was was a functional adult you know
non-criminality in adulthood so they're
white supremacists they're white I mean
I guess you could fill in the blank
after that uh but so when the protest
was happening and you may or may not
recall this conspiracy to commit murder
against an RCMP officer CBC ran this
article showed front and center a cache
of weapons that They seized and it all
looked scary and one of them with a
spoon in it no no this is the one with
the a patch on on a vest we don't even
know if they were ballistic vests
Apparently one of them was arrested you
could only own with a with a license but
still lawful
um so they arrested these men February
2021 and this was the basis to say look
how violent this protest is we need to
invoke the emergencies act and Trudeau
invoked it these men have been sitting
in jail in remand since February 2021 no
trial no bail bear in mind in Canada the
dude who ran who ran over four
protesters in Winnipeg four trucker
protesters people suggest he was antifa
doesn't really matter he he ran over
trucker protesters he was given bail uh
an accused cop murderer in Ontario given
bail these four guys have been sitting
in remand which is even worse than
prison for four years and nothing no
trial publication bans on parts of the
of the of the of the case so people
can't even know exactly what's going on
that's one thing we said four years is
it two and a half years sorry it's been
close to two years that they've been in
jail four of them okay four individuals
on Troy no conspiracy people are saying
that trucker protesters 2022. whatever
it was it was 20 it was when it was I
screwed up a year and a half so they've
been in there for 500 and some odd days
closer to close to the internet yeah
yeah uh yeah I'm not uh Jesus the last
three years in any case yeah they're a
blur man so these they were arrested on
conspiracy to commit murder the CBC
state-funded media runs this photo of
these cache of weapons with the RCM
treatment the picture was like Trump's
classified documents like it's as though
this is what they do in an investigation
you got a pending investigation let's
mix all these weapons up
um Firearms not weapons and make it look
very scary
they arrest them they invoke the
emergencies act and you may recall they
invoked this emergencies act froze bank
accounts came in with a militarized
police force beat the ever-loving piss
out of protesters and then a year later
they had their investigation into the
circumstances leading to the emergencies
act as required under the law we had a
six-week Hearing in front of this
commissioner for the government to
justify invoking the emergencies act
which was with the replacement to the
war measures act in order to justify
violently suppressing the most beautiful
protests the world has ever seen
six weeks the the commissioner hulo
comes out with a 2 000 page four volume
uh document which relies heavily on this
one incident of conspiracy to commit
murder to say yeah there was violence so
Justin Trudeau was justified in invoking
the emergencies act and Justin Trudeau
gets a little pat on the back gets
ratified in everything he did but he
said yeah but trying to get them to
cancel Insurance on trucks that was too
much freezing of the bank accounts was
effective and he was justified in
invoking the emergencies act how violent
was the suppression it was I was there I
was I was live streaming there was
concussive grenades they were they were
they were physically beating people like
they were physically beating some of
them were War veterans this guy named
Chris Chris Deering who was his body was
literally ravaged like blown up in I
think it was Afghanistan but it could
have been Iraq uh it might it must have
been Afghanistan because he's younger he
was literally detonated by an IED three
of his four comrades died
he was physically assaulted cuffed
behind his back this is in the dead of
winter hold on detained for like a
couple hours with his arms behind his
back he lost his medals which were on
his chest when they were doing all this
to him then they haul him off outside of
Ottawa and dump him in the snow and let
him make his way back it was violent and
there was some footage of it where the
CBC accidentally live broadcast
police officers like kneeing like
someone like it was a sack of potatoes
it was violent and I was there the the
Friday and the Saturday where it was
violently suppressed concussive grenades
coming in like Stormtroopers they were
bad they were budding people with their
rifles it's all the videos out there and
then if you put this video on YouTube
the videos get demonetized uh because
you know control control the
dissemination of information
so the commissioner came in and said
yeah Justin Trudeau was justified there
were people who were detained for months
this one guy Pat King for five months on
non-violent mischief charges denied bail
this woman Tamara Leech meti Woman
detained for for several weeks denied
bail because they said if we let you go
you're just going to go promote More
protest the administration of justice
will be compromised if we release you on
non-violent mischief charges political
prisoners left right and Center Tamara
leech she set up the GoFundMe she she
was one of the organizers she set up the
GoFundMe for everybody knows that
GoFundMe was uh Frozen uh the month my
monies were basically seized but then
returned to all the donors then they set
up the gifts and go which got raised 10
million dollars in a day or two they
could never disperse those funds because
the second it would have ever crossed
the border into Canada it would have
been seized under the meriva injunction
she wrote a book called Hold the Line
she was detained I mean for a total of
like 50 some odd days one of the reasons
she was detained was for alleged breach
of her bail terms because she went to a
Gala to receive a freedom award by this
uh not-for-profit called the Justice
Center for constitutional freedoms and
she took a picture with the guy that she
had a no communication order with wow
they haul her back put her back in jail
she spent a total like some 50 some odd
days in jail non-violent mischief
charges another guy Pat King Chris
Barber I mean and the Coots for this is
It's nobody talks about it uh partially
because there's publication bans they
had gag orders uh but this it's like
it's a full hermit Kingdom of they say
like injustices political prisoners that
the world doesn't know about and I think
America should be paying a little more
attention to are there this will trickle
down are there significant like laws or
have there been Court uh decisions
preventing people from talking about
this stuff uh well they're not they
sanction it uh they'll they'll say
they'll sanction it I mean they they've
put um publication bans on on certain
aspects of these cases as far as I
understand pertaining to the evidence or
the lack thereof
um but it's just an amazing thing they
they gag the defendants while they're
out they don't let them go on social
media they don't let them tweet they
don't let them talk about it uh Tamara
leech was only recently allowed to even
give interviews uh and then meanwhile
these four guys are sitting in jail for
sitting in remand I I they they called
me from prison uh it was a week ago it
might be a week I forget if it's a week
or two weeks now and I spoke to all four
of them it's like you know it's amazing
that they can they can remain optimistic
but they've been sitting in jail and
very few people are talking about it
this is the so you say the name of him
c-o-u-t-t-s four so you've you fled
another aspect is you know they're
controlling the media that you can
consume now they've talked about this
thing called the link tax which was
taxing Google and meta for linking
through them to news outlets so you go
you Google something you just click on
the link and you get right to the
original source and the government
passed this bill known as the link tax
which would require Google and meta to
pay it to pay a fee just to link through
to the original source and Google
admitted said piss off we're not doing
it what does the government do they say
we're gonna we're gonna suspend our
advertising on Facebook and meta not
realizing meta doesn't need Federal
funding the way I don't know say CBC
needs there's only 60 million Canadians
they don't have the they're not gonna
have an impact 38 million 30 in my bed I
only want a double thinking they want to
double the population by the by the end
of the century and what Google should
have done is say no problem Canada we
will remove from Google search all of
these companies and then all these
companies would scream in Fury you
because they're right their their views
would drop to zero you'd think that but
um it just allows the government more
control in terms of what you can see
this was this was a a win-win for the
government if they if they do do it and
they're gonna you know have to pay a fee
for linking through to the primary
search results who's that going to be
it's going to be the ones that the
government has determined Canadian
content because of the online streaming
but I disagree like one way to stop
something is a shock to the system and
if overnight you could no longer no
longer Google search any of the sites
you you browsed it would be a massive
like meteor slamming into the cultural
psyche of Canadians I'm not sure that
I'm not sure about that because the
people who watch the alternate
alternative uh journalists alternative
sources I don't think they rely on
Google for that uh what this what this
might have heard would be like the
Legacy Media they say well no no you
know we're not going to get recommended
in the search engine anymore by the way
the online streaming act which is going
to govern the internet the way it
governs radio and television going to
impose Canadian content requirements on
um content creators online but hold but
what about outside websites right so
like uh a Canadian a news Outlet would
be like you got to pay a link tax but
what about an American News Outlet
um Canada well I don't I have to think
I'm not sure I I know offhand how that
would work in terms of paying to an
outside Canadian link
yeah I can't tax on that Canada can't
force
Google Canada to pay an American for
something that American is not
requesting
or they I guess they can they can build
you got to contact them and try but even
even in that regard Google can be like
okay we'll make reasonable attempts to
pay them and then not do it and what
would end up happening is American
sources would reach Canadians Canadians
would be cut off from their own news
gonna have to think about that I'm not
sure that it would work like that in any
event because bottom line is the
internet is regulated now under the
online streaming act in Canada uh
governed the same way radio and
television is in terms of
um in terms of requirements to
contribute create Canadian content and
so on which determines how you come up
with the search engine I got to know
about this online streaming act what the
hell is the online streaming Act is
basically going to um this is an another
amazing liberal law passed in the dead
of night under the cloak of covid which
basically says
if you act like a broadcaster on the
internet we're going to come in and and
impose the same requirements that the
crtc it's the commission Canadian radio
television radio telecommunications I
might be making a mistake on it it's
basically it's it's a it's a federal
agency that governs radio and television
it says okay you wanna you wanna
broadcast in Canada you have to have
certain requirements you got to pay
certain fees you got to create Canadian
content we're doing it to preserve
Canadian culture they come out and say
well a lot of streaming Outlets have
been doing you know uh the hulus the
Netflix on the internet their uh what's
the word bypassing uh the broadcast act
which governed radio and television so
they come out and say well we're going
to govern the online streaming companies
the same way we govern radio and
television makes sense Netflix wants to
broadcast stuff in here you're gonna
have to pay a little if you don't
produce Canadian content you'll have to
pay a little extra tax uh so on and so
forth and they there was an exclusion
because people were concerned if it's
going to govern the internet this way
it's going to govern individual YouTube
channels social media accounts so they
had an exclusion in the law that says we
will not come for individual social
media accounts in the dead of the night
they removed that exclusion and then
when pressed on this they said well why
did you remove the exclusion and this
guy this bumbling idiot uh Steph Stephen
Gilbo says we're not coming for
independent you know uh channels social
media accounts so it's not what we want
to do and the guy says well if it's not
what you want to do why do you remove
the exclusion that said you're not going
to do it if it's not what you want to do
and lo and behold they ultimately admit
yeah if you're big enough as a social
media platform we're gonna go we're
gonna come after you and so this is
going to govern everything the the
pretext is always benevolence we want to
protect Canadian culture we want to
generate Revenue
um it's censorship under the guise of uh
you know protecting Canadian culture
which Justin Trudeau has in the past
already admitted he doesn't think exists
he said crtc Canadian radio television
telecommunications commission and
they're trying so this would make it so
like if the YouTuber a guy is like
destiny.gg has goes online and they want
to be like yo Destiny now you got to pay
us taxes if you're talking about
absolutely and if your content is not
sufficiently Canadian we're going to
require that you don't come up in the
search results as high as Canadian
content like CBC even when they're
reporting on Brittany greiner's Memoir
uh CBC would come up there it's Canadian
content Radio Canada these are these are
federally subsidized federally funded uh
news outlets uh yeah it's it's just they
you know the joke was that it's just
called an alternative media tactic
they're coming after the rebel newses
they're coming after the post the post
Millennials oh geez true north
Viva fry Hey one day Viva you cover a
lot of American stuff even though you're
a Canadian based in Canada we're gonna
we're gonna demote you algorithmically
on YouTube or we're gonna make you pay
fees because you're taking something oh
I dude I could do an entire channel in
French would be great okay awesome yeah
the language police up there they got
the language police in in the province
of Quebec province of Quebec recently
passed a law which removes language for
police and Quebec oh tell them about
spaghetti gate oh well no there was one
it was called what's spaghetti I mean
there's a number of examples about this
but so uh there's an Italian so first
you need to understand language please
uh French has to be prominently
displayed in Quebec so the Quebec is a
it's a it's a French Province not not
the only one contrary to popular belief
New Brunswick I believe is officially
bilingual but Quebec is a distinct
Province spaghetti gate uh I think it
happened when I was actually hanging out
there's like 10 years ago there was an
Italian restaurant that had a menu that
said spaghetti on it and the language
police said where's the French and they
were like what what and they're like it
says Spaghetti where's the French and
they're like what
it's spaghetti and they got fined for
not writing spaghetti prominently in
French and having the Italian words
I need to remember the exact name of it
there's a story why Tim Hortons doesn't
have an apostrophe s all right and it
goes back to this I think it was called
Sam's garage but I might be mistaken on
the name it doesn't matter all that
matters is there's an apostrophe in
there there's no apostrophes in French
so they said Sam's garage that's not
French uh there there was an exception
for registered trademarks they said
that's not French they said well well
I'm gonna put a a Canadian flag over the
apostrophe now it's Sam's without it
without it it's French Tim Hortons
didn't want to have to have two
brandings they didn't want to have Tim
Horton's apostrophe yes for the rest of
Canada so they just go Tim Hortons
without a nest yeah that's that's sorry
without the apostrophe uh so in Quebec
we have a it's called a bill 101 the
language law and it created a bunch of
requirements for businesses uh for
signage the French had to be netmo
predominant clearly predominant it's so
Preposterous that is very French
French is the polite way
I had a client who sold goods and the
goods were measured in ounces and
stamped on the can was ozed and that's
not the French abbreviation for ounce
so this individual literally had to go
over and put a sticker over the ozed and
I think it's OC because it's almost in
French or o n it's crazy they went they
go to like like the kosher stores and
say your your kosher food doesn't have
French on the back uh they go to you
know Chinatown to say well this some of
these things don't have don't have
French it's crazy so how do you how do
you say like
um moo goo gaipan in in French good
question I do I don't know uh cashier La
PESA how do you say that in French I
mean that's that's well there's a
there's a big Moroccan French Jewish
Community anyhow so
um the language law is one thing and
they revamped that law under Bill 96 to
make it even more strict to apply to
smaller businesses oh even better you
can't exempt from having contracts in
French they have to be drawn up in
French
um there was a law recently passed in
Quebec that removed parental Supremacy
from the youth protection act now it's
government administrative bodies that
determine what's the best interest of
the child for the purposes of youth
protection where does that go
forced vaccination or if a kid says I
want to take a shot parents say no well
we'll decide for you kid says I want to
change my sex parents say no well a kid
brings in the state the government says
well it's it's a crime to deny this kid
what they think they need at the age of
40. I got a good idea for uh sci-fi
dystopian short film we were talking
about how we want to do these short
films I really really do we need to find
like a good talented producer and
screenwriter and director uh how cool
would it be to do a the year is like you
know 2083 and actual Canadian refugees
are fleeing Canadian Society is very
much children born in pods through
artificial insemination they're very
much in VR some of these things are in
urban U.S cities but people in Canada
who are like opposed to this have just
all fled and then Canada is this
nightmare dystopian country and there's
like political conflict between the U.S
just Constitution which is harder to
erode than Canada which has completely
dissolved and eroded all of their rights
it would be Canada basically today what
drives me nuts is people don't seem to
be as outraged by it as as I am as
people in my circle are it's there was
another story of absolute Madness this
woman named Sheila Annette Lewis in
Alberta was taken off the organ donor
list because she refused to get the jab
and she sued they put a publication ban
on her Charter application because it
people might get mad at the doctors mad
at the hospital the woman couldn't
specify what organs she needed because
it would have been so specific that they
would have been able to track down the
doctors in the hospital who were denying
the proceed or Who removed it from the
list but she's recently settled you know
resolved that apparently but Justin
Trudeau you know he goes on TV and he's
just like you need to listen to what the
massive multinational corporations want
for you yeah it sounds like they're
testing government ownership of human
beings with the whole your body we're
gonna Harvest your organs unless you opt
out so like that you're born and the
government owns your body
determines when to harvest them you
don't even have to be dead just close
enough when the kids you Google this
it's called
um Allen's law I think out of new it's
New Brunswick or Nova Scotia and the
coroner or the whoever the medical
professional is can determine you're
close enough to death we can we can
Harvest your orchids it's it's crazy and
the only the only piece is
the only people that desperately impacts
are the most vulnerable people in
society those who don't have people to
speak out for them it'll blow your
freaking mind this is and it's true it's
not like Alex Jones and they're 15 years
ago and there are people who choose to
live in Canada
the reality is
um a lot of Canadians prefer a safe
prison of sorts than the risky Freedom
that Americans historically culturally
uh have have chosen uh you know what if
you go live up in the old Tundra up
North so well there is a there is a
movement sort of like there is a
dichotomy in Canada between the west and
the east of Canada the way there is
between you know Texas and Florida and
the rest of the states a lot of people
not West to the point of British
Columbia but it's the Alberta Manitoba
Saskatchewan Heartland who say we want
to separate because Quebec and Ontario
determined policy for the rest of Canada
they keep electing this this dumbass I
feel bad saying that this dumbass
Trudeau who enacts policies that are
very much anti-natural resources that
penalize uh the Heartland and the west
and they said get us the hell out of
here they call it wexit after brexit but
the sentiment of loathing uh the east
has existed for a long time and and
rightfully so we have these things
called Equalization payments so the
federal government collects taxes from
from from natural resources and the
revenues of the provinces and then
reallocates it based on call it poverty
for lack of for lack of a better word
and so they take the they take the
taxation from Alberta oil sense you know
the natural resources and then they
apportion it to Quebec and the Eastern
provinces which are poorer provinces
because they don't exploit natural
resources the same way uh the West does
and so the West is saying we are
financing our oppressors through these
Equalization payments that go up to the
federal come down in Quebec and then
Quebec and Ontario by and large
determine elections so we are basically
financing our own oppression is does
Trudeau have term limits there are no
term limits so you can keep getting
reelected as long as he as long as he
gets reelected but you call them a
dumbass he's worse but I've been polite
evil
evil and what happened I don't remember
him being evil in the early days
the indications were always there
because you you go back and you see you
know the the admiration for the basic
dictatorship of China there was a
Huffington Post I think wrote an op-ed
basically saying in 2015 under Trudeau
Canada is going to turn into China and
whoever wrote that I forget his name and
I'd love to the moment I saw him doing
that that weird handstand thing on his
desk I was like evil he is it really is
the the most Insidious type of evil it's
what C.S Lewis you know said that the
the Tyrant who who tyrannizes you with
the blessing of their own conscience is
the worst type because they'll do it
they'll do it endlessly yeah because
they do they believe they're doing it at
least a criminal if he says the baron
robber at least he'll sleep maybe he'll
be maybe he'll get tired one day and say
okay you've had enough those who torment
you for the with the blessing of their
own soul will do it forever is it true
that Justin Trudeau is the son of Fidel
Castro there are there are rumorings to
that effect I hope so
the hell is that
dude that looks like he's like Satan is
levitating
do the yoga handstand thing I knew he
was evil he's got strings attached to it
he's levitating this reminds me of the
uh the flagpole Trend like from like
five six years it's kind of like
planking but you go sideways like this
but on a flagpole and you'd have to hold
yourself yeah I remember that yeah
impressive but in order to keeps getting
reelected now I'm trying to think of
have I missed anything from the Canadian
political censorshiporeal hellscape well
what's going on with Bill c-16 the
compelled speech law that Jordan
Peterson basically became famous oh
that's that's that's old that's already
law now that was the one that added
gender expression gender identity to
aggravating factors for certain crimes
but that is a like what Peterson was
concerned with actually has come to
fruition oh yeah and I gotta say
something I I did a video on that back
in the day back in the Vlog when Viva
had short hair and was not opinionated
and I said I'll be objective and say you
know there is the old expression in law
bad cases make for bad law and I've
added to that bad legislation makes for
bad law or bad legislation makes for bad
cases which makes for bad law c16 added
gender identity gender expression to the
criminal code for certain provisions of
law notably hate crimes notably
aggravating factors
Peterson at the time said this is going
to result in compelled speech there was
another scandal going on uh I forget the
details of that so I don't want to get
into it uh he he was sounding the alarm
back in the day he was 100 right then we
get into this new law which one is it
it's called the uh conversion therapy
ban
voted unanimously got unanimous approval
even from conservatives and it is
literally a provision of law that says
you cannot talk someone out of being
trans being gay we have that well no
well this this now actually and I know
California is enacting something very
similar which is why I say like people
should be paying attention to what
happened in Canada when you can
violently suppress protests freeze bank
accounts and then have it ratified by an
independent Commission
big big big effing trouble for the rest
of the the so-called Free World um but
there's a ban on conversion therapy it
only goes one way you can tell someone
that they are gay that they are trans
you just can't tell them they're not
which basically as Jordan Peterson was
was remarking turns psychiatrists
psychologists counselors into mere
affirmation uh units right because if
someone says I've got I've got some sort
of mental disorder I feel like
something's wrong with me you know a
good therapist will help you figure out
that there's nothing wrong with you it's
normal to feel weird sometimes like so
but or origin or suggest you might you
might very well grow out of this gender
dysphoria thing which was recognized
forever you might grow out of it so
let's not do anything rash right now
because 90 some odd percent of all that
would be criminalized now a psychiatrist
would have to say I understand you're
good to feel who you are and what can
how what can we do to help you instead
of what can we do to help you
it's interesting actually that's the
first time I've used we had to be
inflection Our Guest on the culture War
uh one of our guests was saying that she
was suffering from gender dysphoria to
the point where she wanted to she was
considering surgery and she talked to
someone who said get your hormones
checked and it turned out that her
hormones were imbalanced imbalanced so
she got prescribed female hormones and
immediately the dysphoria went away
that's probably like that would be
illegal under these things wouldn't it
pretty sure oh yeah no no it would be I
think clearly affirmation is the
funniest thing like some someone weighs
100 pounds and she's just like I'm too
fat you're right you're right
he's ease up on not eating fat I mean it
it is literally that Preposterous where
you've turned uh you've criminalized the
practice of Psychiatry the practice of
psychology although I tend to think
psychiatrists are all crazy in the first
place but you've criminalized it and so
you can you can only affirm it and you
can only convert one way so it's not a
ban on conversion therapy it's a one-way
Street Band on conversion therapy you
know what the end result of all this is
in Canada right
let me think Canada is calling itself
culling calling well so now that you
mentioned that and this goes back to the
other
um not conspiracy theory the so-called
replacement Theory which is you know
racist conspiracy theory uh the
projections are in the policy is to
double the population of Canada by the
end of the century there's no way go
from 38 40 million to 80 million through
immigration because now everybody's
leaving first of all people are
literally the government is literally
ending people's lives in record numbers
people are emigrating in record number
people are leading a lifestyle that
leads to uh not having children in
record numbers government says well
the population's not growing naturally I
wonder why but I mean
no no Sherlock what do we do
immigrants bring them in and they're
erasing uh uh Canadian social order
you know and it depends what even what
anyone even means by that it's what's
clear is that doubling the population
through immigration and I presume it's
going to be legal it's not you know I
don't know what the difference is
between legal and illegal anymore it's
just what the government says doubling a
population in such a short period of
time if it's not replacement it's at the
very it's at the very least dilution
dilute in half the Canadian population
as it is and hope I don't know how they
hope it's going to even work out
financially
if you're not bringing in
um individuals who are going to be
working generating Revenue contributing
tax dollars to the system itself which
is already so depleted it can't support
its own Health Care system if it's it's
controlled demolition I mean there's no
other way to say it is replacement
Theory where if someone's got like a
racist population they're like we're
gonna move in the race that we want to
replace the ones we don't as far as I
understand what makes replacement Theory
racist is the idea is that you're
bringing in non-whites to replace whites
the the thing that makes it races is the
wrong people are talking about it well
you you well but see the thing is it
turns out all of those people were
actually wrong it's not happening in the
U.S happening in Canada and it's not
replacement Theory what it is you see is
uh it's just a cultural diversity and
it's like Canada is not monolithic
ethnically racially but much more so
than the US which is the irony in all of
this the US the most racist place on
Earth and people look at Florida and say
it's a a bigoted homophobic principle he
said Canada I know it is wrong and I got
to listen to these Canadian nincompoops
say how racist and bigoted Florida is I
mean you've never been to Florida and
you've never been to Miami and you've
never seen anything if that's what you
say setting all that aside it doesn't
matter where the population comes from
what you have is an outright dilution of
the political landscape in Canada and I
if I had to wager a bet I don't think
trust and Trudeau is bringing in uh an
immigrant population that he thinks is
not going to be favorable to his policy
and his party and so it's basically a
way of importing votes if you say that
in America that's racist I'm not talking
race bring them in from any racial no no
no no no no no no no no no no matter
what it doesn't matter what you're
saying it's if you say that it will you
will be accused of racism dude I get
accused of being a Nazi despite the fact
that I'm I'm quite clearly a Jew boy I
mean it's like it's it's Preposterous
and if anybody says the fast races my my
retort is my report to that is it is
quite clearly policy because who do who
do who do they automatically tighten up
the borders for in terms of immigrants
Cubans because they tend to vote a
certain way politically so it has
nothing to do with race it has only to
do with politics and that's exactly
what's going on in Canada I was tripping
out just now thinking Trudeau could be
the prime minister in 40. very long time
now there is some talk that there might
be another election you all know that I
ran for federal office yes yeah I
thought you were going to win man oh
yeah I thought I was going to win for a
second so I guess then I realized I ran
for the People's Party of Canada that's
not going to get very far in West Mount
NDG which votes liberal for the last 30
years over 50 I could have put my dog
Winston or my other dog Pudge Pudge
doesn't have a human name Winston vote
Winston for the liberal party they would
have had a dog representing them in
westbound he would have gotten elected
over me
um and maybe that's just how bad of a
candidate I am but there is room Rings
now that there's going to be another
election called
um because there's been a massive
cabinet Shuffle within the Trudeau
regime
the the country is falling apart but
it's it's falling apart by Design and I
and I I can only call it a controlled
demolition because the Liberal Party
would rather rule over the ashes than
seed power to see the country flour to
the Canada oh okay say it again I said
we should Annex Canada Tucker Carl this
is what they wanted to block Fox News in
Canada for me we should invade Canada
they're so St they're so uh freaking
minds and the thing is Canadians hate
Trump almost more than the liberal than
the Democrats I want to bring democracy
to Canada well I'm thinking the other
way can you not appeal to the king to
protect us
people that I don't look as far as it's
detached the king and the Queen have
nothing to do with Canada except in name
only the Commonwealth is part of the
British Commonwealth Kino we'll call it
the Keynotes look at the UK they're woke
to can't the king be like Trudeau you're
out no I I don't know I don't think
there's a legal mechanism for that but
you know what the population could say
the only problem is you guys in the
states complain about a two-party system
there's problems with the parliamentary
system where you have six parties as
well because you effectively have two
parties regardless if Kennedy got
liberals NDP uh conservatives you got
the People's Party of Canada that didn't
get a seat in Parliament set that aside
you got the green party you got the
Marxist party I think you even have a
Communist party at the federal level
well then you have the block quebecois
that's the you have a federal party in
Canada you have a federal party in
Canada whose stated purpose is to have
Quebec separate from Canada go go figure
that uh zenonian Paradox out but when
you have so many of these parties the
Trudeau regime only got elected with 30
percent of the vote at most and I think
in the last election it was something
like 23 yeah so you have a wildly
unpopular loser who remains empowered by
a minority government and only stays in
power because of his Unholy alliance
with jugmeat Singh in the new democrat
party and so this is what Canada is it's
five fractured parties that the loser is
in power with a fraction of the vote and
stays in power because he got another
loser at the NDP who says I will support
you for as long as it takes for me to
get my government pension I am going to
make the liberation of Canada a key
issue for this presidential election
it's the only thing I'm going to
advocate for every time we talk to a
presidential candidate we're trying to
get a debate going I'm going to be like
will you liberate Canada make Erie great
again
taxes How would how would like you know
we've had Vivek on a couple times like
how would a price what are you supposed
to say to that like if someone if you're
actually on like a show and you're
running through the office like will you
yes will you physically invade Canada
it's a joke until it's not a joke by the
way about the invasion about the risk
the Canada can pose you guys know that
once upon a time in recent memory Canada
was training Chinese soldiers for
wintertime Combat on Canadian soil yes
uh 2019 I want to say yes literally they
get caught then their minister of
whoever it is the Minister of Defense
says we're no longer doing it that
suggests that it recognizes you were
doing it I mean you actually have uh CCP
uh actual interference with Canadian
elections and I don't want to sound
partisan but I do believe it it is more
uh focused on liberals actual CCP
infiltration that becomes a national
security concern for the U.S so it's all
it's all fun games until it's no longer
fun and games I mean that's super legit
not only did the Chinese spy balloon
just go right through Canada nobody even
didn't even tell mention it and maybe
they did to Joe Biden but they're also
went to the United States but like it's
a beachhead it's a wartime beachhead if
if if Canada decides at the last minute
you know what we don't think that the
Americans are going to win we really
like that basic indicatorship of China
we want to be a Chinese satellite and
now America deal with us it's the Cuban
Missile Crisis but the northern border
it's going to be like 50 to 75 years
from now
Canada is going to have just like become
this chinese-supported military regime
that's taken over the United States and
subjugated everybody and there's going
to be like these dudes living in an
underground bunker like in ready clothes
as there's like explosions overhead and
they're hiding and then they pull up
this archival video of us laughing about
invading Canada and they're like If Only
They Knew fortunately it's part of the
British Commonwealth in name only maybe
well I mean it legitimately is and the
British are tight with the Americans
apparently so I don't think they're I
would be no we know who else is
supposedly tight with the Americans
Canada this is a good I want to like we
gotta get this short film thing going
because we do want to where a Canadian
guy comes back from you know 50 years in
the future and he tries to desperately
warn everybody of the threat Canada
faces and they all laugh every time he
says somebody believes it 50 years can
you imagine 20 let's just say
pre-covered but let's say 2015 to eight
years someone comes back and says this
is what Canada is going to look like in
eight years you would tell them to go
you know to go straight to but the guy
the guy comes to America and he's like
you need to convince your leaders to
invade Canada and they're like China's
bust out laughing China's going to take
the eastern half of Russia and then
they're gonna have a straight line right
over the pole just what they're gonna
just build roads right through Russia
right over the Atlanta or right over the
Arctic and enter into Canada they're
doing that uh there's a new Arctic Silk
Road they're calling it um and yeah
and I'd be down with a freeway across
the Bering Strait but I'm talking
diploma we're talking we're talking
about Invasion Ian that's a total but
like I'm trying to think have I shown
anything about cam cultural Invasion
does the chat if I I'm so used to
following a chat anybody has if I've
forgotten anything about The Madness of
Canada I think I think we've covered a
little house let's go to super chats
because some people did bring some stuff
up we'll see those crazy and if you
haven't already smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com and uh yeah we'll read some
super chats I'm not your buddy guy says
that's rather unnerving just thinking
about how far the left will go for power
I mean people terminate others for
insurance fraud I mean what would you do
for the keys to America oh debanking
thank you I'm not your buddy guy Nigel
farage do you banking in Canada you know
this Jeremy McKenzie one of these guys
who got caught up with they they debank
people for political purposes I I
suspect Paul Bernardo a convicted
murderer and worse uh still has a bank
account it's it's it's the
politicization of everything and it's
the weaponization of essential services
for politics it's a uh how do you
pronounce it
uh the gulag archipelago he wrote yeah
that uh uh the criminal it was just an
unfortunate Affliction but you knew
better right so when the criminal
commits the crime it's like well you
know but when you do it
let's grab some more Super chats
where are we at let's grab what do we
got some questions
pinochet's helicopter tour says RFK had
powder burn powder burn stippling behind
his ear
if anybody in the chat knows the name of
his recently appointed like a new guy at
a secret service who was the one who
recently died who everybody's you know
who who knows this Theory seems to
suspect is the one who pulled the Fatal
shots
let's grab some good questions I'm
trying to find some good questions or
stuff about Canada but can I can I can I
uh unsolicited I said I would mention it
because have you ever heard about this
guy name you've heard of Phil Damaris no
oh God this is gonna this is another
it's gonna blow your mind because it's
come to the States now Phil Demarest The
Walrus Whisperer he was the guy who got
involved in a 10-year legal battle with
burning land for for whistleblowing on
the bad treatment of of smooshy the
walrus
um that's one separate story but now
he's turned his sights on the Miami
Seaquarium where they have an orca whale
that's been living in captivity for I
think it's 40 years 50 years and so he's
uh
he he's been he's now that he's settled
with marine land marine land moved the
walrus to Abu Dhabi he's turned his
sights on on Marine on um the Miami
Seaquarium and he recently got slapped
in the lawsuit in Florida for flying a
drone over the stadium where this whale
has been kept not for public uh viewing
and he got sued by the whoever owns them
by ABC aquarium uh they want to prevent
him from from flying drones over you
know injunction but uh a worthwhile
cause the guy's Phil Damaris walrus
whisper and uh if anybody does not know
about what's going on at the Miami
Seaquarium it definitely works is that
what they've made Blackfish about uh I
don't I don't actually I don't know
because I this is a terrible I have not
watched Blackfish it's a good movie I
know I'm sure it's really great it's
about a whale in captivity there's
dorsal fin is just bent because he's
stuck so in such tight quartz horrible
yeah because apparently like they need
to build that muscle by actually
cruising the opening this Orca Lolita
she swims in a soup thing uh all day
long for decades and I went there uh
because he held a protest and I went in
and saw what they did with the manatees
the manatees
they're 55 65 years old they live in a
glorified swimming pool I mean I think
some I know people who are not you know
very well to do have bigger swimming
pools than this higher order mammals
living in it's inhumane captivity you
see what we do with chicken City
chickens it looks it's amazing first of
all those chickens look delicious so you
know if everyone sushi
they're humans but why is sushi known as
fish known to be good for Birds oh
absolutely they love it but uh we do
sushi Friday here with like all the crew
and everyone gets Sushi it's like we do
a big order it's like a you know it's
like a team building thing I guess and
then the leftovers the only the fresh
fish portion of the leftovers people
don't eat we'll just throw to the
chickens
but it's like the the Sashimi is the
first thing people pick at because it's
the good stuff you know what I mean but
then we don't give the rice and the
weird sauce to the fresh fish you know
what you want the you don't want the
chickens to be overweight they might
have to come to you and say I feel fat
dude I just got to tell you like you
take a bunch of hens and a rooster and
you throw fish in the hens are like
piranhas I'm assuming it's because they
produce eggs every day so they're
ravenous and the roosters don't so
they're just like whoa like these leaves
all right let's read this one Andrew ho
says Tim you just mentioned the
Australian favorite without naming it
the Tim Tam slam where you bite you bite
the diagonally opposite Corners off and
suck coffee or tea through the soft
chocolate Center I am familiar with tim
tams that sounds amazing I think I'm
going to order some no no I can't eat
that candy okay we can't do it
have you heard about heard of the Shoei
have you guys heard of that it's an
Australian New Zealand thing so it's
where you pour beer into your shoe and
then you chug it I think it's a good way
to get probiotics in your belly
your shoe it's your own shoe but yeah
kofibi King says hey Tim you should
check the 2020 movie called possessor
it's about an assassin who controls
other people's bodies using brain
implant technology to execute high
profile targets freaky movie cool
there was also gamer
where uh the bad guy has these Nanobots
that he can control you once they go
into your brain I mean that's that's
based on nature where you have those
insects that get uh you know the power
supply and they go up and commit suicide
oh yeah and Grasshoppers and stuff
that's what uh Last of Us is based on
cordyceps get to humans and then they
become fungus and I might have to say I
think it's not actually cordycep though
I could be wrong maybe it is but Paul's
damage was like it's given cordyceps a
Bad Name all right Hank the Hokage Hill
says Viva please talk about Pierre
poison
the leader of the conservative party uh
I never tell anybody who to vote for uh
I will vote PPC myself for obvious
reasons I don't trust the conservative
party which also unanimously voted to
support this anti-conversion bill uh
he's charismatic he kind of looks like
Clark Kent
um
but uh
Pierre poliev supported the trucker
protest when it became politically cool
to support the trucker protest and then
threw them under the bus when it became
uh toxic to do so because of the results
of the commission he also threw if we're
if we're holding grudges which I have
not been known to do I'll forgive but I
won't forget he threw um Christine
Anderson under the bus remember
Christine Anderson the European Member
of Parliament who came here
she took a picture with I'm gonna forget
the exact circumstances
but bottom line he called um Christine
Anderson one of the European
parliamentarians who was uh radically
critical of Justin Trudeau and of what's
going on in Canada he called her uh you
know xenophobe and you know islamophobe
extremists who shouldn't have come to
Canada because she came to Canada to do
a tour that that was borderline
unforgivable in my opinion
um so yeah that's that's piafully he
might he might be a better alternative
but he would not be my first choice he'd
continue to support the truckers after
the council would he have been just
erased from politics I don't know um I
think he's gonna get well he's not going
to get a race from politics now because
there's no alternative but it would have
been the Principal thing for him to do
he was slow to support the trucker
Convoy then he did it when it was cool
and then he dropped them and pivoted
when it was no longer cool to do so oh
but that reminded me of one other one
other craziness out of Canada this uh
member of provincial Parliament Joel
Hardin for the new democrat party I
don't know if you heard about this there
was a protest that I went to document it
was uh it was education not induct
Nation put on by billboard Chris and
this 17 year old kid always want to get
so embarrassed if I can't remember his
name now Josh Alexander geez
I go to this protest I get home the day
after that night and apparently a member
of visual Parliament was physically
assaulted punched in the face by the
hateful anti-trans uh yeah we saw this
yeah and I'm like oh that's serious
if that happened let's find the person
who did it hashtag Justice for Joel
and I said call me crazy if a member
provincial Parliament were punched in
the face by an anti-trans protester
something tells me the CBC would cover
it Global News would cover it Radio
Canada would cover it but they weren't
and I said oh we gotta find this person
hashtag Justice for Joel they found the
person the dumbass bumped himself in the
face with his own bullhorn the internet
literally I mean it's so amazing when
you have like 12 live streamers on both
sides you see the moment they caught the
clip they caught in his face well
they're not someone bumped into him and
it pushed into it was not punched he
wasn't punched then he comes out and
does an interview and says oh I was hit
it's like well we see the video and you
literally see the metal eyelet where the
I guess where the the what do they call
those things that go around your neck go
into you'll see him go into his freaking
face and I watch a lot of UFC I've never
been in a fight I was like if that came
from being punched in the face there
would be bruising around the sharp
incision not just a sharp incision
busted busted busted never apologizes
the media never covers it of course and
that's it goes on he's a sitting member
of virtual Parliament all right here we
go Maya solely says hi Tim my BF and I
are both huge fans and have been members
since April I was hoping you could shout
out my boss's GoFundMe he has a
blueberry farm and back in may we had a
freak Frost and he lost about 70 of his
crop
Sobieski's River Valley Farm sounds
delicious sounds great best of luck in
that uh
dtqc says currently working on a project
that will remotely disconnect electrical
vehicle recharge stations for the
purpose of power balancing it will be
mandatory to install for new apartment
buildings how could that go once you all
have electric cars
there's another short film we gotta do
we should write these down it's uh this
is really easy and some of these could
just be like three minutes long a guy
gets into his car
and then you have a couple things happen
his battery of his car is at 30 and he's
like ah geez and then he like he's like
why wasn't it charging and then it's
like an alert and it's like energy grid
advisory due to excessive heat vehicle
recharge has been disabled and then the
other one is a guy gets in his car and
he's backing out and then all of a
sudden everything shuts off in the car
and then he's like oh oh crap and the
screen turns on and it's red and it says
warrant detected for for driver you know
David fry or or you know whatever and
then it's and then it's like uh uh you
know delivery to Precinct 37 and then
you're like and then the car drives you
to the police station where the cops are
waiting for you yeah or or you know hey
we found out that you donated to the
trucker Convoy disabled vehicle or
assassinations via vehicle which is also
something that I believe has been
discussed with probably already happened
numerous times
they've been hacking cars for over a
decade
well I mean to be completely honest
they've been cutting brake lines for a
long time you know what I mean true this
just seems much more Diana yeah it's
done remotely that's why it's weird all
right Billy know says no for household
solar the inverter that changes the
power from DC to AC needs an outside
charge is like an alternator in your car
if you don't have that outside power it
will not work
so like we have solar setup and then
when the power goes out the solar
batteries kick in and power the house so
I don't know what I'll say you know what
I mean like we don't need the grid
that's the point I guess I don't know
whatever
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
what do we got
what do we have here I feel naked not
being able to follow the chat have I
been getting insulted in the chat no
people are going crazy they're just like
he's the worst no they're like the best
oh yeah when I looked at a few times
they're jazzed oh yeah it's like most of
super jets are just like we love you
well dtqc I know from uh from from my
community at least I recognize a couple
of names outer PC says the last three
years remind me of when I got out of
prison they say you only do two days in
the joint the day you go in and the day
you get out the rest is a blur just like
the covered years oh man yeah no it's
amazing it's it's March 2020 two weeks
to flatten the curve and we are in 2023
where the U.S just lifted their vaccine
requirements to cry to cross the border
in Canada
oh that that well that was another
interesting one where there was a 2020
law a 2001 law from Quebec that
seemingly allows for compelled that
vaccination people only recently
discovered it and thought it was new
legislation we've been on this we've
been on this trajectory for a long time
we just
yeah it had monkey pox as one of the
specific illnesses named in it I think
it might have been uh the other I want
to say the swine flu or the avian flu I
think it was one of the swine flues 2001
give or take so whatever the virus was
then the terrible rabbit of death says
asking for a favor if Tim could give me
the info on the medical intervention he
got in Mexico I have bolt cartilage in
my hips destroyed both cartilage mustard
three years ago and I could use some
info and help here in Canada we don't
have a lot of help it is the cellular
performance Institute they are based out
of Tijuana and uh Joe Rogan talked about
it on his podcast with Eddie Bravo and I
think it's come up more than once Eddie
Bravo's talking about how it like
totally fixed his shoulder it is not
cheap it is not cheap but uh take a look
at their website it was it's it's it's
an experience I got to tell you watch
their videos you're in this room with
all glass windows like so it's like
there's a there's a back area where
there's doors and stuff but then the
whole left side in front is glass
overlooking the ocean where there are
dolphins jumping around and it's just
the beach it's the boardwalk and you're
sitting in this chair if if you're up to
the window but you can just see like
dolphins jumping in the air and stuff
it's like wow they hook you up on IVs
take your blood do all the work these
are real dolphins real dolphins out in
the open ocean in the actual wall and
and and like extremely close to humans
and there was even a seal laying on the
beach it's that's Tijuana were you in
the clinic the whole time or did you go
to a hotel and back hotel and back okay
and and then hilariously Tijuana has a
chain of casinos that are like like
McDonald's basically you walk into this
very small like 2 000 square foot casino
with like one dealer and that's that's
when we how long ago were you in Tijuana
two weeks ago is it I mean like I am a
very fearful person I'll never go
technically is it is it as bad as I've
been a Tijuana crime rate I remember
looking it up was atrocious no no it's
fine I was in I was in Tijuana last week
I we we uh we we were there Friday
Saturday what did we do uh Saturday
morning
no Friday night we flew to Vegas
because we're like we're coming back and
they have this thing called jsx which is
uh just sex jsx is an airline
and uh their original Airlines 30
seaters but they fly out of private
terminals so it's super easy you walk
right on the plane awesome and it's like
the same price as a regular flight they
just have only smaller planes so they
don't got to go through the standard BS
but I think it's dude uh so here's the
thing here's the secret they they tell
you about places like Tijuana and places
like Cartagena and uh Cancun
you as a American or Canadian tourist
are probably totally safe because if
anyone screws with while you're down
there the cartels will Flay them alive
this is what was explained I was this
was explained to me by some journalists
who specialize in South America 10 years
ago and it's the same thing I hear from
people who live in Mexico and live in
Tijuana and live in Cancun there was a
guy literally last week told me the
story that there was a town in Mexico
that had a casino and a resort
and someone kidnapped an American
and it was a huge news story
within a month or so the casino was out
of bit like was dead and they were on
the verge of collapse nobody was booking
anymore Americans panicked and didn't
want to go there
the cartels got extremely angry that
their source of income was destroyed
so there was another story where this
was happened recently
someone on America two Americans got
kidnapped by a cartel member the cartel
searched their ranks to figure out who
did it and turned them all over to the
authorities
so the general idea is you are the money
for these people when you come to
Tijuana you may get pickpocketed someone
might snatch your purse or something
like that but for the most part people
stay away in terms of crime from
tourists because
the the like justice in this place for
people who take the money away like from
the cartels is not what we would in
America would describe as Justice more
so like
I don't know criminal harm you can
understand the financial repercussions
for Crime I understand that rationale
I'm still not going if that's the way
that law is maintained it's like imagine
you're walking down the street and
you're like wow look at this Delicious
Restaurant and then a guy's lurking
behind you and then he's just gone
it's just like you you I gotta tell you
man Tijuana was amazing we were walking
around it's totally safe
tourists 2007 it was phenomenal it's
worth seeing just to see the border wall
from the other side it's really close to
the Border
my wife went but it was 20 years ago
took a bus and then walked over the
border and said um did not have a good
experience but that was 20 years ago but
also I I that's like it's a safe town
but don't you know don't get lost or
don't go here or don't go out at night
then I'm like that's not a city I'm I'm
going to avoid one of our friends has
got like a very nice vehicle it's a very
flashy and he's like never had any
problems you know there's there's
probably crime but it's probably not in
the area in the areas where most
tourists are at and
for the reason to described now I don't
know to what extent that's that's like
the case because it's like I'm watching
cartel members snatch people up but it's
basically what everyone will tell you
like don't worry the cartels have your
back it's not it's a good thing but you
know you'll be okay it comes to the same
it's just for different reasons you went
to Vegas you said did you see that giant
eyeball thing yeah what is it okay
what's the giant eyeball Madison's the
sphere the new building okay how long
ago you were there last week okay uh
last Saturday did they they just
finished it and just opened maybe a
month ago yeah yeah what is it like it's
a giant building with TVs all over it
it's a venue but on the outside it's a
floating eye it looks like a big it's a
building shaped like a sphere with TVs
on it and they can make it look like
whatever they want for a decade when we
flew in it was the moon and these
amazing and then one was the earth and
it's spinning the dog eye is creepy I
think a gigantic dog eye looking around
I think you two is gonna be their very
first event there in September or
October but the tickets are gonna be
insane because it's not that big of a
venue but it's crazy they said what you
see on the outside is very similar to
what you see on the inside so if you're
sitting in the crowd there's like a
screen like you're completely immersed
that's amazing if YouTube's gonna play
they better not play a song off that
album that came with the iPhone a while
back yeah I remember that one two three
fourteen whatever he he would say
or whatever oh no
you got it one two three fourteen no the
controversy for me was you got an iPhone
and it came pre-loaded with an
unerasable YouTube
Tim it wasn't called spaghetti gate but
pasta gate because the pasta section was
named pasta in an Italian restaurant in
both their French and English menu but
pasta was used because it's the Italian
word
it's ridiculous it's all ridiculous when
you have a law that's been in effect for
40 years that doesn't yield the desired
result the law is the problem not we
have more law we have a correction
self-made woman says correction Avery's
law New Brunswick yes and it was the
organ harvesting law fry was talking and
it was named Avery's law because uh a
young kid 15 or 16 was in a what turned
out to be a fatal car accident I believe
and they wanted to donate his organs but
the infrastructure wasn't there to allow
for it so the solution became
presumption of organ donor and I guess
that's so they can have the
infrastructure in place whenever they
need it but you know another tragedy
that is politically exploited to produce
a result that has nothing to do with
actually avoiding the problem in the
first place
Spiro floropa says Vancouver right here
Viva explained What's Happening Here Tim
says to leave cities and be independent
I have 50 50 custody with my child and
will lose if I leave I have no choice
but to stay and fight if I want to be in
my child's life what can peeps like me
do to fight back Behind Enemy Lines to
help or to help others
okay the number one rule of law they
said if you want to stay wealthy don't
get divorced and um marital stuff will
make culture everything but now what can
you do
I I say I say raise awareness and public
shaming who's I just talking to where
they said tyrants don't respond to
public shaming no they respond to a sway
in public opinion when the public
shaming has worked on those who have a
conscience there might be the few
politicians out there who have a
conscience that can be swayed by public
shaming the rest will only um will
change based on public opinion which can
change based on public shaming Eric Mack
1 says I heard that Canada has oil
sounds like Canada needs some U.S
Liberation yeah we got we you got oil
they just they don't they don't want to
exploit our natural resources they
prefer and I say Trudeau prefers to buy
from Venezuela and Saudi Arabia you
could use a little democracy up there
got oil sands and it got oil sands God
there's a lot of gas uh gas and oil off
Newfoundland I mean we got we've we are
natural resource rich but we prefer to
buy from tyrants because it makes us
feel better not to make it but that
makes me think that Canada will become a
target for Global military action if
they have a ton of oil and they're not
using it it's just well that's our oil
there are there are suspicions about
foreign interests Chinese interests
buying up massive amounts of interest in
certain natural resources or certain
properties and you know there is that
concern I don't know enough about it to
to economic global economic action let's
read we got uh Carlos Weiss as Tim I've
sent to you a hundred thousand super
chats trying to ask congressmen if they
will table a bill to buy Alberta we'll
trade oil for Freedom you can't buy
Alberta would be the wrong Province to
do that anyway
conquer California should Annex British
Columbia since you know spiritual and
ideologically they're they're quite
aligned amen um I say that I say that
tongue-in-cheek so that no one thinks
I'm anti I'm checking the map right here
that's the whole problem with Quebec
separation it would separate The
Maritime Provinces physically from the
rest of Canada you can't do that we
conquer Alberta and you have no say in
the matter because it is your land we'll
be conquering yeah you might not meet
that much resistance we'll be greeted as
liberators
invade Canada oh man that would be great
I'm not your buddy guy says please
invade I would gladly join the U.S oh
there there's a lot of well it depends
which state I mean California New York
including the U.S maybe like true who
knows but nobody's gonna do
ideologically there would there's a lot
of alignment in certain parts but big
cities yeah California is much like
Canada
Robert Bradbury says Tim's just talking
Fallout 3 which I'm playing right now
such a good game Fallout 3. what was uh
The Fallout 3 references yeah it was a
good game just tell me the apocalypse I
guess what I'm really excited for is uh
and I mean is somewhat sarcastically
they're they've already got a mod for
Skyrim where you can actually speak into
a headset into one of the characters who
can respond using chat GPT
I can't wait to try that kind of stuff
out now you can download it right now
and play it okay on Skyrim now yeah so
basically you're in the game and you'll
be like a companion where do you think
we should go and then the companion will
respond being like perhaps we should go
to this place that's really taking video
games to the kind of the next level for
for immersion wait until they can
neurostimulate sexual arousal and then
you can play a video game and actually
have meaningful relationships with the
character I've never played we talked
about this the other day like we are we
are a year or two away from not neural
stimulation but when they already have
mods for Skyrim where you can actually
talk
yeah it's going to be seamless you're
actually going to play You're gonna be
playing like
it could be a mod or a new game could
come out within two or three years and
you're wearing a headset and you walk up
to the a character and you say I need
you to join me on my quest and it's a
random NPC Auto generated by Ai and
they'll be like me what's your question
like I am a noble Knight going to fight
a dragon and they'll be like I can't
fight a dragon but it doesn't matter you
are coming with me and they'll go dude
you're crazy I'm out of here and they
run away you run to another person say
how about you do you want to join me on
my quest of like sounds good to me
what's your name and they'll be back my
name's John Smith you'll be talking to
people and they'll and then you'll be
like hey go fight that wolf and they're
like you got it and then they'll run
over and start fighting it and you're
just like that's it's gonna be nuts I've
I've never touched or seen anything
personally but Fallout 3 or Skyrim so I
have no idea how those games work but
it's gonna be it's gonna be so crazy
it just sounds like it sounds like
social media where you just never know
if you're actually interacting with a
real human or a ball but people are
gonna play games there's gonna be a
there's gonna be some duties an Intel
guy right it was in his basement he's
gonna play the game and he's gonna see
this beautiful female NPC character
named you know Anna Smith and he's going
to be like I choose you to be my maiden
and she'll be like yes it will remember
everything you say because text files
are not that big and then you'll come
home from work turn the game on and be
like how was your day and it's like well
I was tending to the Sheep but Dragon
attacked and first of all did you say
Anna Smith because of Anna Nicole Smith
or was that just a random it's amazing
um have you seen that there's a common
name is it the movie her or she her I've
never seen I've never seen anything with
Joaquin Phoenix I mean this sounds like
the plot of that movie yeah basically uh
Google has uh they made a AI with like
video game with like 30 AIS and they
gave very few parameters and then came
back to it and they've created like
Memories like different AI characters
with each other and stuff you know what
the scary thing is going to be when
you're playing like GTA what are they on
six when you're playing GTA 7 and you
walk up to a guy in the street and you
say something like I'm going to end your
life and they beg you they beg for their
lives it's gonna be nightmarish and
those games I just want to say this have
you as everybody who's ever played a
game with
um morality meters or whatever you'd
call it like Fallout has it yeah Fable
stuff like that right everybody the the
Trope is you play as a good guy and then
once you beat you're like all right now
I'm gonna play it again as a bad guy
yeah then you kill everything now no and
then it's gonna start the game and the
guy walks up to you and the first one he
says like my son died and you can choose
screw you haha or I'm sorry for your
loss you're sitting there staring at the
wanting to be mean going I can't press
it I can't be mean like nobody people
have a hard time playing the bad
character and being evil I don't know
man it's pretty easy to pick up the
hooker in GTA and then take her behind
the building but GTA is not a game where
you're you're like so in Skyrim and
Fallout you you are building relations
with the characters where they talk to
you and ask you for things and you have
to choose to be a bad person to them
okay so what people will do is quick
save be bad and then load and then not
be bad I'm really concerned for the
games that are persistent worlds where
even when you log off they're they're
still going because then the people will
miss it they'll be thinking about like I
can't be logged out I have to be in
there or I'm gonna miss you're gonna get
a phone call from your NPC wife like you
were bringing this up you can call NPCs
they'll call you yep and they'll be like
it's time to harvest the crops for 199 I
can harvest the crops for you oh my god
yup and you're gonna be like uh
authorized purchase okay when you come
home you're gonna have fresh watermelon
available for your plague for your game
it's a mate this sounds amazing I'm
gonna stick with NES Contra uh and I'm
gonna turn it off good game up up down
down all right I finished a game without
losing a life yo me too without already
I got uh I was talking to a customer
service AI bot that said and I was like
human it goes I could answer a lot of
questions why don't you try ask me
anything and then I'm like no I want to
speak to a human but I can answer your
questions try asking like we're already
there where this creepy bot is trying to
be the you know how many lies did you
have when you beat the game after you
didn't die unconscious but I don't even
use the up up down down left right left
right A B I used the code but then I
didn't die and I had like 33 guys again
yeah you get natural life every day you
end the game with an intact if you don't
lose a life with seven extra with seven
men
six or seven so it would have been 14
minutes and 57 seconds didn't lose a
life nice work all right everybody
spread gun it's Friday night oh yeah
that's right of course everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends buy our coffee new Blends are
now available Mr boca's pumpkin spice is
back and I recommend you buy it now
because we are selling those very very
quickly stand your ground is currently
unavailable I guess everybody really
wanted the medium roast and uh you can
become a member at timcast.com you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally on X at timcast
this right in the App Store it now says
X there you go Viva you want to shout
anything out uh of all of my platforms
so Viva Barnes law which camera look in
this one this one
vivabornslaw.locals.com for an amazing
community of legal analysis political
insights and a lot of family stuff
because uh I add a lot of the family
stuff there in terms of a crayfish from
the Potomac River pinched my kid's hands
today
I asked him what did he learned I
learned nothing so I threw in a little
Stewie clip um Twitter angry Viva V Viva
fry or x uh what else Rumble Viva fry
those are the uh and if you Google Viva
fry you'll find everything
always a pleasure man oh yeah I also uh
just wanted to mention apparently we're
approved to launch in the in the App
Stores timcast app oh sick I don't know
if it's there yet but uh it might be
that'll be fun not yet but I guess we
got clearance to do something soon but
if you go to timcast.com there's a
mobile app section so you can download
the Android one at least see I am uh
philibonti Phil that remains official uh
on Instagram Phil that remains on
Twitter or X whatever you want to call
it I don't care uh the band is All That
Remains on Spotify Apple music Pandora
YouTube all the places you know I'm Ian
cross on follow me at Ian Crossland on X
and everywhere else mines YouTube you
name it you go there I'll probably be
there and hit me up good to see you Dave
always a pleasure man really good to see
you thank you very much now I'm on to
the next leg of the journey with uh down
to Florida so we'll see if I can get
there tomorrow it's like 14 hours in
good weather but might have to break it
up over two days godspeed my man thank
you uh and you guys can follow me at
Kellen PDL I'm a supporter of the Great
Alaska expansion uh that's what I'm
gonna that's what I'm gonna call it and
actually we get Dolphins out here in
Maryland uh some occasionally they'll
come up the Potomac River in the
Chesapeake Bay occasionally too so right
on but yeah fun show thanks guys thanks
for hanging out everybody we'll be back
with Clips throughout the weekend and
then we'll see you on Monday